oh bonjour à tous et bonjour Fab salut
keV salut à tous donc Fab on est reparti
on est reparti attends j'ai pas la cam
là pour le moment je suis un peu en
sueur je te cache pas
ça y est j'ai la cam
alors attends il y a une des gammes qui
marche
sur un cafetière non c'est la cam et
chiquier de nakamépo mais je pense que
les autres vont partir aussi
on a pas la cafetière mais bon on a on a
les chéquier alors attends j'envoie le
raid
il y a tout qui va partir on va
récupérer l'autre échiquier aussi
évidemment
on va découvrir avec vous la position
et ben voilà on est bien Beko
c'est parti déjà là c'est parti il
envoie
ah non c'est l'arbitre c'est l'arbitre
c'est possible
[Musique]
le cheval en G3 le cheval en C3 tu es à
deux doigts d'avoir une vraie position
déjà G4 c'est impossible tu donnes
je pense ce 4 ça a l'air logique non
il peut aller vers E3 ou il refont
pareil B4 B5 A4 ils font toujours ça dès
qu'il y a une tour à une dame côte à
côte sur l'aile il pousse comme ça
intéressant quand même ce truc de voir
que quand c'est à côté comme ça ils font
systématiquement ça G4 H4 B4 B5 A4 ça a
l'air d'être théorique non
j'en sais rien
si tu reviens à zéro et que je leur dis
qu'est-ce qu'il dit juste un petit alors
déjà il pense que c'est au noir de jouer
bon et il te fait du coca et G6 ou B5 ou
B6 donc c'est enfin B4
il y a une vraie logique quand même dans
le fait de développer
après je me demande laquelle est mieux
placée celle-là à 8 ou salon à 4
tu peux faire baisser l'autre côté ou
quoi alors c'est l'heure à 8 elle est
quand même
[Musique]
condamné à être à être surgit d'eux qui
est bien défendu
c'est un truc tu arriveras mais voilà la
moindre souplesse
est-ce que tu penses B5 toi c'est un
plan genre très con pour juste aller
gagner le Punto
peut-être après
mais oui ça peut te sembler 5 en soit je
trouve l'idée bonne ça
il y a une des cases latérales et tu
prends la caisse du cavalier
tu fais des choses
on disait que j'ai trois Fougères en
fait sur G3 il t'aurait fait fou B7
mais ça donne un peu la cadrer c'est
bizarre comme position non mais en fait
si tu as le temps tu fais B5 celui de H4
là tu es beau
[Musique]
ou pas enfin je suis pas sûr parce qu'on
peut pas quand même faire baisser
en fait
après il peut aussi faire trois qui de
toute façon un coup utile
mais cinq possibles aussi peut-être il
veut pas laisser pousser cinq trop vite
peut-être qu'il veut jouer des coups
avant et dès que tu bouges ton foot il
fait des cinq
j'aime bien les pots
ouais ouais moi aussi mais
déjà pour les Noirs mais l'un dans
l'autre ce qu'il y a de bien avec les
Blancs c'est quand même une meilleure
structure oui
donc bon
en soi si tu fais juste un développement
et que normalement tu auras un avantage
s'il y a pas un truc trop fou qui se
passe avant je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec toi
tu as pas de dinguerie tu vas être mieux
parce que c'est 7 et à 7 sont tout de
suite touchées
5 pour le cheval et tu t'attends fouette
et là tu fais baisser 5
peut-être
mais je t'aime bien il le fait un jour
ça va être ce qui m'embête c'est ce qui
est H4 qui rode sur un fou de quoi
[Musique]
c'est complètement con ou pas
bon
[Musique]
mais tu peux peut-être faire
et juste de faire qui avait V5
en fait peut-être parce que c'est
défendu non
bah écoute toi c'est logique vous B de
Slash fois 3 bon pourquoi pas
[Musique]
c'est chaud mais bon il joue logique
il joue logique du coup il va les gagner
plus ou moins 7 j'imagine enfin
peut-être à tomber ça pour défendre mais
tu as pas très envie mais
du coup c'est pas très logique que la
quête comme ça
les blancs peuvent être quasi gagnant
mais ça se peut que ce soit avantage
noir aussi cette position là c'est dur
de savoir
qui arrive en premier en fait ce que
c'est le dynamisme
ou est-ce que ou est-ce que c'est le
placement stratégique bah ça joue les
coups les plus logique cavaliers de
tempo
5 ou H4
ça a l'air de faire mal c'est la merde
alors ça tu veux pas évidemment
en fait quand tu vas mettre le four en
B2 tu peux mettre peut-être faire grand
rock en réalité ah non t'a plu parce que
tu as fait tu auras pardon
[Musique]
ça me fait peur
des fois ça dure longtemps
j'ai plus envie de pas plus de merde
avec quoi j'ai trois dans F3 et
ça donne pas envie
il a repris de dés
complexe comme position mon Fab
ouais ouais mais ça joue enfin on
comprend ce qu'ils font après tu vois je
peux pas te dire à quel point c'est bien
ou pas mais il y a de la cohérence de
part et d'autre à la position était plus
normale on a tout de suite ressenti
donc il espère bien
j'aurais peur avec les Noirs quand même
mais il y a pas vraiment de menace en
réalité
ouais ça va
qui a appelé ouais ça peut bah ça sera
probablement la partie en fait j'en sais
rien mais
prend ses 6 c'est faire des débiles
après tu peux commencer par cahier des 4
et du coup on reprend du Fou et de
préparer le petit rock c'est peut-être
ça le plus logique au final
et B6 est-ce que c'est complètement con
pour prendre à 7
je sais pas non ça a l'air con l'idée
c'était de bloquer un peu le cavalier
mais en fait il a des rebonds et en plus
il y a 5 des 5 cavaliers aussi ça a
l'air débile
là il est très heureux ça prend un peu
la canette
ça va danser là il va y avoir de la
grimace qui va partir
c'est un peu une chemise pinyple encore
je pense qu'il est très heureux et
je crois qu'il est très heureux
on se regarde un peu à gauche ça regarde
un peu à droite ça fait un peu de la
grimace
j'adore que ça y est ça c'est reparti
des petites grimaces
le café là je pense
il a l'air très heureux
il fait moins le malin contre Ricardo ça
joue moins vite
c'est beau c'est peut-être spécialement
une stratégie contre Magnus
au cas où
j'aime bien
furtifs et
genre en fait ce soit là ou l'autre ça
serait leur premier titre de champion du
monde de n'importe quoi non je crois
ouais
on vient à mon historique
ok oui
bah écoute c'est vrai que ça se passe
pas trop mal pour lui
[Musique]
il est peut-être plutôt mieux après bon
c'est loin d'être fait la position elle
est pas non plus écrasante mais
la solutionné son problème sur le pion a
et il est plutôt mieux développé etc
donc il a il a largement laissé passer
l'orage qu'on va dire on aurait pu être
un petit peu inquiet pour lui au début
de la partie mais il a bien retourné le
schmilblick avec son F5 F4 faute sat là
qui était bien senti cette attaqué
claire à la loi
complètement
en tout cas ça réfléchit
un peu
il a fait cavaler des cartes on va le
voir arriver à l'écran
mais tu as vu la jeter un petit coup
d'œil à anaka
on le sent un peu sué Yann oui
complètement
ouais c'est plus difficile que contre
Magnus forcément
c'est la finale et Carus c'est un joueur
clique fort en face rompu alors qu'il
avait le dessus quand même des pots hier
dans la tactique face à face à Magnus
donc il avait en quelque sorte son
son territoire où aller ou aller
chercher le joueur norvégien là il Caro
il est plus dur à prendre c'est un peu
comme pour Maxime qui a du mal aussi
contre Caro
je peux pas le prendre sur sur ton point
fort habituel
parce que ça fait réfléchir car vous
c'est déjà ça
car
éventuellement les noirs peuvent prendre
après même il peut commencer à regarder
des coups comme E5 ou je sais pas
il y a tout un tas de coup possible pour
ikaro
prix semble logique
ça libère la case mais ça peut être
c'est 5 ça peut être 5
alors après c'est 5 juste tu te dis que
ah mais il l'a fait ouais tu te dis que
tu bouges ton cavalier et puis bah du
coup le n'a pas été libéré tu relates à
ça quoi mais
peut-être ouais
[Musique]
si tu veux avant ou après et tu coulis
c'est pas tu trouves un agencement de
pièces comme ça quoi tu passes par la
phase pour B7 ou tu as l'air dégueulasse
mais qui va pas durer ou tu vas faire
des cinq tours rebouches et tu vas tout
envoyer au centre voilà de toute façon
faire [ __ ] des deux ou deux
[Musique]
c'est quand même une belle diagonale Fab
des deux c'est modeste
mais ça te laisse pas dans un clou à
chiant
tu as tout à 3 aussi peut-être
autre chose ok tu t'enlèves du clouage
mais tu n'as pas Damas pour l'instant
comme la tour est attachée
donc tu laisses un coup au noir de faire
ce qu'ils veulent
ou je sais pas quoi
un peu chiant
ok il y va
mais témoins bien avec les Blancs c'est
sûr
plutôt bien mais bon
tu gardes ta pression sur assiette on va
dire au moins tu as un argument mais tu
t'es pris le centre
non ça me fait penser enfin a priori tu
es censé être moins bien mais bon ça me
fait penser au grand vide ou les trucs
comme ça on avait vu tu as un pion de
plus pour contre ça quand même
parce que c'est un gros centre quand
même pour les noirs
donc faut deux rock et peut-être après
fou des deux et tout enfin ouais avec
les mains tu vas peut-être si tu as le
temps fou d'eux rock ou des deux tours
enfin moi je préfère avoir les Noirs
j'aime bien avoir le centre mobile comme
ça mais
l'objectivement je sais pas ce qu'il en
est ça quand même une dame à 8 un peu de
débile
même tu fais un truc tu aimerais bien
faire comme E54 tu vas quand même devoir
perdre du temps avec ta dame
après c'est deux trois coups oui oui
mais ça peut ça peut avoir son
importance
tu serais déjà là où tu dois être
oui c'est sûr que là tu es pas
bizarrement la dame à 8 qui était bien
parce qu'elle appelait un fouet 7 pour
pour jouer le long de la grande
diagonale c'est vrai que ici finalement
elle est pas si bien placée
étonnamment
en tout cas c'est Yann qui est en
difficulté dans cette partie il
réfléchit déjà
il est 18h
c'est rien en fait ouais mais je crois
qu'il a très vite cliqué au début
ok normal
un coup de développement il renforce un
peu le cavalier F3 qui pouvait être
fragile sur des tours F3 pour jouer
cavalier H4 il prépare le rock
normalement ça va être autour du
cavalier maintenant de sortir à moins ce
qu'il fasse tomber cette tour Eiffel
bon il a pas E5 j'imagine
sinon ça aurait été content
tu peux commencer par cavalier F7 et tu
peux pas en quelque sorte
tu prépares ou tu reviens vers Saint qui
était change le KF3 je sais pas pourquoi
avec comme ça dans le mouvement
tu as qu'à l'envie de les changer c'est
la seule pièce qui défendra si tu fais
kf7 qui a valu 5 que tu échanges les
chevaux et que tu reviens vers G4
soit pour coulisser soit pour se barrer
avec la dame en B8
et à revenir sur une autre diagonale et
justement avec un cavalier 5 reprend de
la dame ou du fou ou quelque chose
et elle est par là-bas en tout cas ça a
tourbé ça tel défend le pur à 7
bon je vais voir ok de toute façon
ça paraît être une obligation
je le vois pas jouer un truc comme H4 H5
G4 ici non
et on aura une position d'échec plus ou
moins normal enfin c'est normal quoi
ce qui aurait pu commencer après un B4
au premier
genre de raoutant non
ouais ouais ou de je sais pas quoi de D4
des 4 poisons je sais pas quoi en fait
mais non ça peut semblable à plusieurs
choses il a ok
ce qui peut avoir un jour des E4 pour
essayer de forcer des 4 et se regagner
la casser 4 pour le fou
surtout quand il y a 5 de jeu en fait
d'autant plus ouais
on va voir Fab comment on commence à
continuer
et là je pense qu'il va faire 4
maintenant
sur ce centre
bien joué ce tour B7 là pour décaler la
dame et éventuellement repartir vers F7
c'est pas évident d'y penser tu te dis
Bessat c'est la casse pour le fou mais
en fait
c'est plutôt la casse pour la Tourette
exactement ça c'est vraiment très très
bien pensé c'était pas facile
ça c'était vraiment pas facile à avoir
alors qu'on voit un petit public
derrière
ils sont à deux doigts
ils peuvent sortir du fumigène Fab
j'espère qu'il y a la sécurité au cas où
petite suspension de terrain quoi
qui envoie des grimaces
qui a sa petite canette verte je sais
pas ce que c'est comme boisson l'avion
de la verra pas j'imagine
le Apple quelque chose quoi
ça doit être douceur ananas à mon avis
il a la facilité
il a l'air très facile
il est très tranquille
mais il est fort
et il est sûr de sa force sur de son
plug
on va avoir un local des deux et le
mieux connecté
il a son petit dieu seul qui repose le
cache
ils ont une petite table basse du coup
pour les joueurs
on dit que ça doit être un minute mètre
pomme peut-être
je sais pas on dirait que c'est un truc
à la pomme ouais
[Musique]
annoncé chez Fabien
c'est beau hein
c'est bon les jus de pomme
du truc vivant et dans la canette ouais
ce serait terrible
canette vibrante
en tout cas ça réfléchit sec côté Yann
il ne nous a pas habitué à ça non
mais c'est pas levé rien en plus
il est très facile quoi
un peu plus dans
complexe complexe
après comme tu disais il a moins de
retard moi j'ai l'impression qu'il a
déjà 10 minutes de retard il a que 4
minutes de retard hein
c'est déjà quelque chose mais c'est pas
énorme ça donnait pas cette impression
en fait si tu vois si on n'est pas la
pendule
au début il a enchaîné les coups de
merde en fait
et maintenant que c'est plus dur il
réfléchit
complexe
cohérent après elle va peut-être il veut
garder ses positions comme ça il se dit
bon bah c'est pas terrible je bouge pas
trop je fais un coup de fou
mais bon c'est pas génial ouais au 4 ça
paraît plus dans l'esprit de la position
pour essayer de contester un peu ce
centre après je comprends quand tu es
sur l'echiquet c'est des coups qui sont
durs à jouer
au cas déjà il y a peut-être des quatre
qui part et
alors ça te donne une belle pièce C4 ou
quoi mais bon
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai vu sur le petit
échiquier qu'il avait joué un coup
de thématique pour essayer d'un petit
peu casser le centre
Ikao c'est D4 tempo laisse-moi boire mon
jus de pomme tranquille
c'est peut-être du jus à la Vera l'aloe
vera pardon cactuses
et tout non
je crois ouais pour les brûlures c'est
bien
logique il veut repartir vers b2c4
ou peut-être fou C4 et vers b2d3 aussi
en tout cas il veut bloquer il veut se
mettre sur case blanche et un petit peu
bloqué et revenir avec le cheval sur une
belle case
et 5 minutes d'avance donc après cette
séquence
va-t-il l'utiliser ou est-ce qu'il va
essayer de mettre la pression
sur la pendule
je pense pas qu'il va réfléchir 5
minutes
non je pense pas non plus il devrait
jouer assez vite bon voilà il va ça va
déjà partir vous allez retire sa main là
mais il fait [ __ ] c'est logique il met
la pression sur le pion B5
et ça va peut-être ok B5 contre A7 au
final cette histoire femme
bon tu donnes un pion passé mais tu
tolère présentation tu ramènes ton
cavalier
bon père
François
[Musique]
c'est sûrement ce qu'il a pris beaucoup
de temps
soit tu prends pas avec les Noirs mais
du coup les blancs vont peut-être un
bloqueur en Détroit assez vite
et du coup à 7 la faiblesse est d'autant
plus flagrante
on nous dit que c'est peut-être du Red
Bull lime
ah je connais pas
ça serait bien dans le Range de dikao le
mystère est entier
ce serait beau qu'on ferait des
interviews d'après partis ce serait
tempo d'autres questions qui oui
confirmé ce serait pas oui B4 B5 je sais
pas comment tu vois quoi en fait
moi c'est vraiment le derrière là qui me
bute absolument en fait
il a l'air très étroit non il pourra une
finale de championnat du monde ça me
bute d'avoir le roller comme ça juste
derrière il me met il me met très très
bien ce rôle
la porte de sortie de secours c'est je
trouve c'est exceptionnel il a pris ses
trois prix C3 ça c'est logique mais
peut-être faut pas faut pas gagner le
pion en fait peut-être je sais pas un
cavalier
je sais pas quoi
probablement pas aller le chercher ce
pion en réalité
soit que soit même
pas
mais d'accord mais je sens le cloche et
sur dame prend
très bien joué
tu vois leur dire aux commandes de
rentrer là-dedans c'est marrant
tu as deux pions tours
entre une dame et tu as le pion assis
quand même qui est fort
en pratique ça peut être super simple
après j'ai l'impression que tu es quand
même fou c'est 6 dans ma huit non mais
on n'a pas trop de doute que je reçois
mieux qu'une dame de plus mais
trois fou français 3 puis on prend
tu penses qu'il part pour le sac fils de
dames ou c'est trop fou
c'est bon c'est une troisième option
mais si c'est le choix entre les deux
pions passer lié qui avance et un pion
de moins ou l'autre je préfère l'autre
bon il fait 5 alors je sais pas trop ce
que ça va donner
il doit chercher des compensations un
peu à l'arrache quoi un peu alors l'idée
c'est quoi sur cavalier prend il veut
quoi
en F3 échec il faut prendre F3
ta prise en B7 intermédiaire OK
et s'il prend B5 en premier
bah ouais je sais pas trop sûrement le
coup quoi il veut quand il veut [ __ ]
en B5 fous prends B5 cavalier prend B5
cavalier prend le 5
il faut prendre
4 et quoi bon c'est pas les deux pions
doublés dessus c'est ça c'est moins pire
mais bon c'est quand même mal mais ouais
mais si ici tu pouvais juste faire
cavalier C3 et qui est pas fou prends H2
mais disons ouais 6 bon ça ça irait en
fait exactement tu bloques un peu le
pion là
donc c'est la partie 5 AB il faut
prendre
ça va être la partie cette enchaînement
et Hikaru qui va peut-être prendre
l'avantage dans ce match dès la première
partie Fab
avec les pièces noires écoute il était
bon dans la partie là
il a été exceptionnel
bonne conception le tour B7 il a trouvé
assis dur quoi
il a été extrêmement fort
le joueur américain sur cette première
partie en tout cas maintenant il faut
conclure il a eu du mal hier Magnus à
conclure
contre Yann
ça prend des 5 ça prend le 5
rien de plus logique que ça
il va tenter de s'accrocher au fil au
branches au liane
rien du tout en fait
tu tombes comme une merde
on va voir si elle réussit à tenir
en tout cas Hikaru qui fait de la
grimace qualitative ici
il est en train de se demander pourquoi
tu joues Yann
il est vraiment beaucoup trop faible
ça fait des petites grimaces à gauche à
droite
encore une ouais c'est le festival là
c'est beaucoup trop et ça grimace plus
du tout côté Yann
ick c'est plus du tout qualitatif côté
Hikaru c'est interro c'est de
l'interrogation pourquoi tu es si nul en
finale de championnat du monde
il doit se dire ramenez-moi la tête à
magnouche je veux ma chance pour le
titre
mais le titre il est ici
on n'est pas du tout allé voir ce que
fait Magnus mais on va quand même jeter
un œil à la cam
on a jeté un oeil Fab et on va tout de
suite revenir sur la finale
là il a été jeté
tu aimes bien ces petits tu veux que je
te le refasse allez
en fait on revient parce qu'on en a
absolument rien à [ __ ] du match pour
la troisième place Fab et oui il est pas
bien Magnus alors attends il a joué
quelque chose de complètement différent
qui était pourrir les pions
c'est laisser pourrir la structure
bon ok
le problème en fait c'est pourri mais
l'autre aussi donc je sais pas c'est
soit tu es mal soit tu es mal après bon
c'est une histoire de
ouais c'est un choix
toujours difficile c'est chaud de savoir
qu'est-ce qui est le plus pourri
bah c'est de prendre le truc où tu sens
ta tête le plus de chance de
m'embrouiller et au moins ça évite de
prendre 5 et il faut prendre 5 et
peut-être qu'il y a B5 en l'air tu es le
H2 en l'air et compagnie quoi
mais bon c'est un choix qui peut se
comprendre façon toujours difficile de
savoir qu'est-ce qui est le moins pire
donc elle va dire
tu es foutu
faut passer un appel à animal ici
le coup de fil à un ami
retourner la situation faible
dur comme position
je prends F3
bon après elle doit pas être si simple
enfin nous réussirait pas à le terminer
là non
pas du tout moi je prendrai la nul ça
j'aurai pour tout échanger faire nul
dans la finale
je perds ce j'ai change toutes les
pièces et je touche pas la finale de toi
avec un plan de moi ah bah oui on va la
tenir femme
mais
en fait j'ai du mal à voir où sont les
chances d'arnaque
ouais mais t'inquiète si c'était nous
qui jouions on allait les clés
F4 tu mets le fond des 4
et les pièces bien placées
contre l'ordi c'est sûr qu'on gagne pas
il doit te défendre ça ça va être
insupportable
attention
téléphone sur vibreur
c'est con
sa critiqué les acclations de Magnus
Impres mais ça fait selon la même chose
de quoi tu parles en fait violine
tu comprends pas qu'on rigole enfin
c'est terrible
level intellectuels
merci à toi
c'est incroyable en fait c'est
terrible parfois mais pas ça va pas
parler
faut dissocier humour accusation ouais
mais c'est pas le second degré c'est
pour certains ce n'est qu'une
température cela
c'est un peu complexe
perception de Fabi ah bah ouais fabiant
défense centrale non pas pour qu'il y
ait des Charlots qui viennent
casser l'ambiance dans le chat tu viens
nous enfin voilà pour moi ça m'énerve
mais bon j'ai pas envie d'être énervé
c'est cool mon Fab en tout cas il a
priage de il est revenu en F4 il va
prendre ses 5 c'est bizarre ce roi il
est tu as l'impression que tu vas être
mate en quelques coups quand même
il est là
alors
après damaset
je sais pas pourquoi ouais mais attends
je pense que c'est juste que tu perds un
peu tes pions
c'est très bien vu
ce sera absolument pas trouvé mais c'est
pour ça en fait l'ordi enfin c'est
impossible de le battre en fait tu fais
tous les trucs logiques et tout d'un
coup il y a un truc complètement
du tout
enfin alors dis confirme quoi par parler
de quoi après lui il va sûrement pas
trouvé ça je veux dire mais il doit
sentir que c'est pas si simple ouais
après l'autre l'autre variante est
peut-être trouvable genre tour C3 vous
prend F1 tours F1 de F4 ça c'est
peut-être plus dans le range les dames
des trois
et tu défends le truc et tu essayes de
récupérer là mais bon tu as quand même
d'options de moins tu vois kb7 tu fais
la gueule
mais c'est plus quelque chose comme ça
qui peut trouver
et bizarrement tu vas peut-être
récupérer ces cinq et tu
as qu'un pion de moins et tu fais un peu
le dos quoi
dès que tu changes les dames c'est plus
c'est grave c'est tout doublée 3
mais bon ça se trouve ça va il a une
autre opportunité après on verra
qui va arriver
après je comprends il doit vouloir
toucher le cheval pour bloquer la tour
et ici si le cheval bouge je tape le
pion
et sur dame 5 est-ce qu'il voudrait pas
un foie 3 mais j'ai peur qu'il te
reprends au 4 ici
ouais ça peut être juste 4 prises 4 F3
et peut-être tu
vois ouais bon c'est trois pions la
qualité le roi faible
ça a pas encore joué côté icaru dans
deux coups il récupère 5 minutes
il y a une qui grimace
il donne l'impression de réfléchir un
truc
tu lui fais peur
qui lui fait même très peur à Yann
il est là en tout cas pour le moment
tu peux peut-être espérer s'il y a plus
les dames et les fous que la finale soit
nulle avec les deux tours et le cavalier
parce que c'est vrai que tu as des
chances de récupérer un pion quand même
hein
un peu bizarre ouais ouais si tu manges
c'est 5 ça doit être nul après
c'est quand même pas si loin de nul que
ça
et que une minute trente de retard c'est
pas le temps ça va pour lui après
généralement il a asséché original non
c'est position là il va envoyer dame 5
et le coup principal
vous cliquez avec peu de temps il sera
là aussi
par le coup c'est un coup de
centralisation
bah oui ça donne un peu des idées de sa
crise de qualité
c'est fort
c'est pas facile à avoir un talent le
damasuta 7 tu auras 8 non c'est dur non
plus ouais enfin complètement à contre
sens du jeu
là sur le logo de la canette ah bah oui
ça serait beau de savoir
sinon il y a personne qui reconnaît
vraiment formellement c'était une
boisson islandaise après un qu'on ne
connaît pas
ouais
il y a des
enfin genre tu vois pour les MMM aux
États-Unis ils ont un truc spécial bird
cacahuète que j'ai jamais vu en Europe
quoi
le paquet orange un peu moche quoi mais
c'est pas mauvais quoi enfin
nous on a juste sélection un peu comme
les smarties et elle est normale peanuts
[Musique]
non parce que
tu reprends des 8 c'est quoi c'est Dame
G5
c'est pas trop dur parce qu'on récupère
à la fin OK
et
ça comment on termine le boulot
va falloir beaucoup de coups en fait
mais bon ok enfin du coup et tu joues
avec ta qualité de moins mais il est mal
quoi
mais bon parfois 29e coups il te reste 3
minutes avant les soins tu peux être
tenté de tempo
à mon avis pas à ce niveau
c'est peut-être que qu'est-ce que tu
fais d'autre avec les noirs
alors attends on va voir il a pris il a
pris ça
alors il y a eu prise et prise c'est
au
de la part du Carouge
non mais il a vraiment bien joué c'est
parti très propre
il y a rien à dire il a complètement la
victoire il était bon dans le placement
de pièces au début dans le l'agencement
et la phase tactique évidemment aussi
mais il a trouvé le assis là il a bien
conclu très propre il a pas fait durer
pour rien
[Musique]
et il a l'air
affûté
voilà ça abandon
c'est tout ça rentre tout dans le dame
j'ai 5 et puis tu as le droit pourri
enfin rien qui va ni le matériel ni le
roi
tu as même pas de contre chance là ouais
était dans la même situation hier oui
bon non trois victoires d'affilée
donc attention attention à Yann dès la
prochaine si hyper par contre et qui a
2-0 je pense qu'il sera condamné
bon après tu sais jamais ça fait penser
à l'heure quoi
c'est pas celui de leur en face Fab non
mais en gros bon on l'a déjà vu
rarement mais c'est pas
après c'est le
c'est le scénario qui me fait peur pour
pour Yann
mais bon comme hier c'est vrai qu'il
était vraiment dominé dans la première
partie
et finalement
[Musique]
terrible
mais oui non mais là il y a pas
il y a rien à faire là je sais pas il va
abandonner a priori quoi
facile mais il faut qu'on lui ramène
quelqu'un de plus fort
jouer des coups du jeu d'échec on sait
même pas pourquoi
le sait-il lui-même
ça a l'air
c'est juste une pièce je comprends même
pas le problème j'ai l'impression que
comprend pas non plus non mais bon
j'aime bien qu'il réfléchisse
par principe en fait
c'est bien quoi
[Musique]
tu assures les arrières
après je sais pas combien il va avoir de
pause Fab parce que il va falloir
attendre aussi que l'autre match se
termine bien évidemment ce match pour la
troisième place qui a
qui va un petit peu venir polluer le
dynamisme de la grande finale du
championnat du monde mais c'est
tellement logique fable de faire jouer
la grande finale et la petite finale en
même temps
dommage faut arrêter de dommage ouais ça
aurait été dommage
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt bien
pensé au contraire
permet d'avoir les deux matchs en même
temps
on va être bien comparer comment ils
jouent leurs ouvertures chacun
avoir une pause bien méritée entre les
rondes etc
il tente
il espérait le tour pour toi il voulait
pas
juste rien non je crois qu'il voulait
juste faire tourner
[Musique]
bon après écoute il peut il peut il peut
jouer quelques coups s'il veut
[Musique]
il fait de mal à personne
complètement
c'est beau et ça permet d'avoir deux
trois grimaces supplémentaires côté
hikao
qui font toujours plaisir
mais c'est beau quoi tu as l'impression
qu'il se casse il se décarcasse encore
c'est un genre de Ducro quoi
je suis là
il essaie de trouver je sais pas quoi en
fait
parce que
t'as même pas d'espoir d'avoir une
finale qui pourrait peut-être devenir
enfin comme une pièce un peu moins
je sais pas ce qu'il espère je comprends
en fait moi non plus
de tourger 8
mais bon c'est très con quand même
mais bon c'est un piège très con
piège comme ça pourquoi pas
malheureusement c'est juste 10000 m par
les carreaux quoi
le problème c'est que tous les pièges
vont être vu en fait
j'adore la tête du carreau en fait genre
absolument rien à [ __ ] en fait
ce qui peut utiliser tout son temps
comme ça bah il a le droit il va juste
perdre autant mais il a le droit
oui
après il se fait plus de mal qu'autre
chose
vraiment être acteur et jouer dans un
truc comme The Office ouais
franchement dans The Office il serait
excellent non
étrange de la part de ne pas là je
comprends pas je comprends pas en fait
c'est rare que les joueurs ils essayent
de s'en sortir dans des trucs aussi
désespéré
tu penses
je sais pas trop quel rôle lui donner
quoi
je comprends pas en fait pourquoi il
joue
ça me ça me dépasse complètement en fait
[Rires]
absolument jamais
donc puis on prend le 3 l'idée c'est
tourner deux évidemment donc pour C2 il
l'empêche
je crois qu'ils adorent mettre des trucs
en prise quand même heureux
pression sur F2
il va faire tourner fuite après ok donc
pour préparer
ou de 7
ou même n'importe quel coût qui te perd
pas un truc en un
devrait faire l'affaire
partie qui
dure est-ce que c'est fini à côté
je crois pas hein
côté
[Musique]
il a bien de plus
mais après il a l'air d'être bien bloqué
je sais pas trop ça peut se tenir
du côté du carreau
ça semble un tenable
F4
peut-être faire tourner vite faut trois
là non pour essayer de te pousser le
pion sur blanc et mettre la dame à
manger 5
Yann qui continue à se battre
ça gagne 4
il prend il prend la tête dans ce match
et le match pour la troisième place on
va on va jeter un petit œil Fab
c'est quand même un match
aussi important et oui
il y a pas de cavalier
prend des cinq mais bon tu peux revenir
Magnus s'en fout complètement je crois
que tout le monde s'en fout en fait
c'est ça qui est beau
d'où l'intérêt de faire jouer ce match
quelques dizaines de milliers d'euros
d'écart quand même
ouais
c'est pas une grosse différence
non mais pour ab12 c'est peut-être un
plaisir de jouer un match contre
ministre quoi
tu dis ok c'est cool
prends Magnus je comprends que c'est
aucun intérêt quoi
c'est un peu comme un troisième match de
poule au master ou de joueurs sont
éliminés et que je sais pas imagine tu
peux jouer Djoko et que tu as un musée
titre un mec comme ça tu es content quoi
dans l'autre sens
pourquoi je suis encore là jouer avec
tu demandes pourquoi tu joues
mais tu sais pas en fait non
mais tu joues juste pour jouer tu
cliques pour cliquer quoi
tu joues pour jouer
en salle des profs c'est insupportable
ouais mais moi aussi je trouve que c'est
pour moi c'est terrible en fait comme
image mais après
en fait il y a dommage c'est que je
pense qu'il pourrait faire dans la même
salle mais juste avec un autre angle
caméra quoi
mettre des rideaux des trucs tu peux pas
avoir des budgets enfin je sais pas le
budget total du truc ça va être
au-dessus d'un million de dollars et
jouer dans un truc comme ça enfin genre
ça n'existe pas en fait c'est ridicule
il y a même pas le nom de Carl scène
devant regarde il y a qu'un des deux
et j'ai au bout d'un moment on est dans
enfin là on est dans du ridicule c'est
ça peut passer par un match c'est pas du
champion enfin ça peut pas en fait il
devrait y avoir un minimum quand même
non mais je suis d'accord enfin
dispo dans toute l'Islande je sais pas
tu vois j'imagine un cas de figure
complètement improbable
même là quoi mais ce qu'il y a de fou
c'est quand on joue l'Open c'est mieux
que ça quoi on est dans la salle
on s'appelle ce truc c'est un truc
magnifique qui donne sur la mer c'est
une salle de d'opéra en fait
où il y a des congrès il y a des trucs
quoi enfin c'est mais qui veut pas avoir
la cafetière derrière le roller dans la
cuisine de l'Opéra quoi on est vraiment
dans le et même les les joueurs
regardent c'est un bout de papier
imprimé devant
c'est du papier imprimé scotché
une imprimante mais
le minimum c'est une table de chaise un
échiquier pourquoi c'est si important la
salle bah je sais pas c'est un final de
championnat du monde quand même enfin
c'est
non mais c'est comme si
on va de la plus pour le marketing qu'on
parle c'est pas nous on s'en fout en
fait on peut regarder la partie mais
pour le public et du coup c'est pas
sérieux c'est comme tu fais une finale
de Grand Chelem tu peux avoir un grand
stade ou tu as 15000 spectateurs ou tu
as un terrain de tennis avec un filet un
peu troué bon tu dis bah c'est pas grave
on verra bien c'est le passeport et des
arbitres et que tu es qu'un spectateur
dans un sur des chaises je sais pas où
quoi tu vois enfin il y a un standing
quoi que auquel tu t'attends je crois
qu'il se fait arnaquer Carlson non c'est
possible
il a juste du bol que vous prend G4 qui
est prend 4 ou H5 et D6 qui est D6 tours
prend le 5 soit peut-être nul mais en
fait c'est comme hier il est pas assez
fort tactiquement dans ces positions tu
vois regarde il est énervé
[Musique]
je pense vraiment qu'il est pas en forme
en fait je pense qu'il est trop en
dessous puisque quand il fait ces
champions du monde de Blitz ou quoi il
est pas mal quand même en général il se
parle à chaque partie quoi
ouais mais c'est plus dur à 960
tactiquement
donc là il a un peu de bol mais ça
aurait pu être juste matte
mais
bon encore un peu défendre parce que bon
mais c'est du bol
un peu beaucoup même
mais ça doit le faire
c'est oui je pense ça va
il a changé de case derrière un moment
j'imagine on va le voir il y a un petit
décalage là cette fois-ci avant
je sais pas
ça doit
parce que tu vas bloquer le roi avec les
pions non
avec le fou
et ça abandon mais bizarre ce qu'il
avait l'air dégoûté nos diabète sur la
cam c'est une petite tête genre ouais
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça fait un zéro
ouais
tu peux être fort si tu as pas la
tactique c'est trop dur ce jeu ouais non
mais je sais pas
en forme quoi c'est clair la main oh
pris du fair-play Magnus quand même on
nous a dit pendant des semaines qu'il
était très bon perdant donc ce serait
bien d'avoir une cohérence dans le dans
le chat
toujours très respectueux quand il
perdent ça
non mais là pour le coup il a pas mal
abandonné
mais
non pris du fer plage je sais pas de
toute façon c'est
des prix qui existent on sait même pas
pourquoi
pas si chaudes
pas mal quoi
dans d'autres sports je peux comprendre
qu'au tennis tu refuse un point où tu
corriges le juge parce que tu as vu
quelque chose au foot on donne un
penalty tu dis non il y avait pas perdu
[Musique]
tu as des gestes à faire quoi aux échecs
c'est dur quoi il fair-play non mais
c'est vrai que je suis pas de faire plus
on parle quoi
c'est beau quoi c'est
quelqu'un qui écrit dans le chat mais
quand il a pris le droit à la vidéo elle
est quand même exceptionnelle tu prends
le roi tu enlèves la croix et tu le
refoues sur qui est
devant les ont bien remis le scotch
ça va le boulot qui est fait
c'est déjà fait sur l'Autriche qui est
mais ouais non tout ça pour dire je sais
plus quand on en parlait donc tu peux tu
peux organiser ça sur une estrade et
enfin c'est pas trop compliqué quoi
c'est une allure de championnat du monde
en France en ce moment le Cap d'Agde par
exemple dans la pièce avec une seule
machin enfin ça donne une allure de
championnat du monde c'est pas on ne
demande pas
demande pas la lune
bon après ils mettent beaucoup d'argent
pour le tournoi les islandais et c'est
super qui le fassent mais ils ont les
infrastructures
c'est pas grand chose en fait en réalité
le vampire tu prends ton truc déroulant
et tu le déroules à fond quoi et tu vois
pas les trucs derrière tu peux tu peux
faire un habillage tu as pas faim tu as
pas forcément besoin d'une très belle
salle pour faire un habillage ouais
quand on parle du Z event tu vois nous
on y était en vrai la salle ah oui tu
étais pas là toute fin ils nous ont
montré les photos je crois de comment
c'était avant qu'on arrive je peux
imaginer mais en fait oui enfin la salle
elle est catastrophiques mais en fait
c'est tu mets une moquette aussi
et la salle elle était super
et ça rendait super bien il y avait
plein d'activités il y avait les
plateaux etc donc c'est plus toi et tu
mets de la tu fais un habillage tu as
très vite un super résultat en réalité
surtout que tu peux
raconter une caméra en fait ta langue de
la caméra tu vois parce qu'il y a
derrière donc tu peux tu peux laisser
des cafetières derrière ou quoi on s'en
fout en fait
complètement
vas-y je reviens dans 3 minutes vas-y
tout de suite
avec la porte de secours ouais mais nous
en fait c'était une obligation de
laisser la porte de secours
accessible donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
pas mis de
de panneaux de vent mais en soi
bon soit c'est parce que ça n'était un
peu trop petite par rapport à ce qu'on
faisait
pas trop petite ça avait un peu moins de
monde il y aurait vu personne à notre
place à nous en réalité
les joueurs connaissent la position des
pièces 15 minutes avant la partie
les chaises sont terribles ah bah ça
après les chaises et les joueurs qui les
choisissent
ça commence quand ça reprend dans
10 minutes je pense normalement ça a 15
mais comme l'autre partie a fini tard
peut-être dans 10 minutes
petite sale petit public plus facile à
mettre en oeuvre les mesures en tea
triche ouais bah après ça c'est une
question de volontaire même dans des
grandes salles c'est possible de le
faire faut juste vouloir vérifier mais
là maintenant il y a beaucoup plus de
vérification donc ça devrait
ça devrait le faire
on voit tout à tout est remis en place
pour que les joueurs puis jouent à la
deuxième partie
et ça va reprendre je vais faire une
petite pause après femme
je vais laisser faire revenir moi je
ferai la petite pause après
je vais déjà mettre aussi la deuxième
partie
on va faire comme eux on va préparer la
suite
voilà la position de départ on l'a nous
aussi
on aurait le public qui vient jeter un
œil à cette position justement
ça va reprendre très très rapidement
il y a un budget chaise dans ta parole
d'acheter une chaise depuis 50 euros ben
je crois qu'il propose des chaises
et chacun décide qu'elle chaise il veut
tu faire un roto 2005 en 960 sur chescom
bon non
[Musique]
une petite pause aussi Fab
je te laisse attends je te mets le chat
sur l'écran pour que tu l'es aussi
avant de partir si tu veux répondre à
quelques questions comme ça tu as tout
ouais
en fait dans les modes de jeu genre tu
vas dans jouer échec en direct
et
tu as ta cadence est un petit déchiquier
tu peux jouer à la vente que tu veux
et donc tu as 960 tu as les trois échecs
de la colline etc on clique sur 960 avec
la cadence que tu veux et puis c'est
parti quoi
donc voilà après le truc malheureusement
tu vas pas trouver énormément
d'adversaires
mais bon
qu'est-ce que je dise comme chaise pour
commencer
dessus et voilà
je l'ai pas pris spécialement pour
commenter mais juste comme je suis
souvent sur l'ordi chez moi
tu es bien assis quoi donc
voilà c'est un peu un instrument de
travail on va dire donc plutôt que me
casser le dos avoir mal et voilà j'ai
pris ça il y a quelques années
pantoufles
Homer Simpson la classe
mais
oui un petit peu quoi
je vais aller faire un tour en Irlande
avec Seb Mazet il y aura Mathieu cornet
on va aller la clinique enfin
[Musique]
novembre plein décembre je pense en
Espagne dans le sud de l'Espagne
après je sais pas trop on verra et
récemment on avait pas mal joué la Coupe
d'Europe des Clubs avec Seb on était
avec d'autres clubs allemands et on a
fait on a fait troisièmes donc ça arrive
encore mais je joue beaucoup moins
qu'avant je vais faire largement
sont partis c'est clair mais peut-être
110 120 130 je sais pas là maintenant je
sais pas si on joue 20 ans par an c'est
maxi quoi
je pense qu'en différé c'est juste à des
heures pour jouer ton coup un coup
toutes les 24 heures tous les je sais
pas quoi on dirait bah tu cliques genre
tu fais un bide ça diminue ce que tu
veux
parce que je constate de faire du 360
960 pour progresser en tactique non
enfin faites du 960 si vous voulez en
faire mais si vous voulez travailler la
tactique travailler la tactique et ça ça
suffit
ce que je rejouerai dans un film bah
c'est pas prévu mais écoute on n'est
jamais à l'abri
comment est-ce que je fais ce brushing
alors ça c'est très naturel
je laisse faire naturellement les
cheveux alors ça va bientôt reprendre
peut-être on va voir
à quelle heure ça commence bon c'est pas
mais là vu qu'ils sont assis je te
dirais que si moins de 3 minutes ça
reprend
quelle histoire du chat 960 a priori
finalement de Fischer qui pensait que
c'était l'avenir des échecs justement à
cause de trop de théories etc et qui a
pensé que c'était une bonne idée de
jouer à ce jeu
voilà
donc il y a keV qui est de retour voilà
il s'est réinstallé je suis de retour
enfin bref
une heure de décalage aussi cette
semaine
qui sort les titles
22h du coup le nocturne
mais du coup il sera 22h
ou ça tu t'en fous complètement
je crois que mardi enfin j'ai des trucs
là j'ai peut-être un match de tennis je
sais pas trop c'est comme tu veux
[Musique]
c'est pas mardi j'ai tenu ce jeudi
championnat de la Loire là attention
je sais pas si ça tente ça fait
longtemps qu'on t'a pas vu ouais
je regarde exactement je te dirai après
je crois que mardi c'est férié
pour ton cours mais juge
c'est le premier ou le 2 c'est le
premier
le test plus marrant à suivre bah oui ça
clique un petit peu le title
puis il y a de façon
ça a commencé une heure avant c'est sûr
parce qu'il y a des calages horaires à
17h il serait 16h ça commence à 16h ça
joue complètement différemment que la
première ouais
pourquoi
on arrive à faire 16h Baki
est-ce que toi tu veux tenter 22 heures
non peut-être on verra absolument rien à
[ __ ] si tu veux tu fais si tu veux pas
tu fais pas à savoir que nous à partir
de mercredi après ouais c'est le 2 on
commentera
bah oui le championne
le chess global Championship
ça va être magnifique
avec des belles des belles califes qui
ont eu lieu
pour moi la position est symétrique
j'ai toujours pas complètement compris à
trois
je comprends que tous mes deux tous les
pauvres mais comme il y avait il faut
prendre un G7
ou un peu mystérieux quoi pour le moment
c'est symétrique est-ce que tu penses
que Yann il veut essayer de gagner des
salles avec les Noirs je pense qu'en
fait 960 tu t'en fous des
tu pars pas en disant je vais faire nul
au noir ou genre nul est un bon résultat
je pense juste tu te joues et puis après
tu vois ce que tu as obtenu
tu cliques et tu vois quoi
ça réfléchit côté Yann de côté n'est pas
pardon le côté
960 trucs à Baki au title
au rugby
il y a des matchs
et oui le retour des testsmatch Fab avec
un Français Australie
samedi prochain à 21h
chez les coqs
ils vont être reçus ouais je sais pas si
on va pas c'est 5 ici et tu te dis je
tiens
j'aurais jamais fait mais c'est 5 let's
go
ouais j'ai l'impression que tu joues un
peu les premiers cours au hasard et tu
vois ce que tu obtiens en fait
ouais mais ils sont importants pourtant
ces premiers coups ouais mais comme tu
peux pas savoir j'ai l'impression que tu
les cliques un peu
tu vois tu copies l'autre je peux vous
dire
comme ça regarde tu es un connard toi
copier mais c'est marrant la proportion
de position les noirs sont finissent par
être mieux genre c'est
ta position tout seul quoi c'est loin
d'être rare quand même
ah il y a le Mondial féminin de rugby
aussi important ouais ouais j'ai regardé
un match le premier match d'ouverture de
la France
les joueuses françaises c'est très très
fort au rugby
après je crois que ce sont les les All
Blacks qui sont favoris
comme d'hab le tableau ouais on a battu
l'Italie 39 à 3 mais ouais demi-finale
très difficile surtout que ça joue en
Nouvelle-Zélande
par le garage maison
au monde
après on n'est pas faim on n'est pas
favori contre la Nouvelle-Zélande mais
les trois dernières confrontations les
avaient battues on a gagné en 2021-29,7
38 13 et 25 16
donc on peut on peut les battre les
Blacks
les Anglaises numéro 1 ouais mais bon ça
joue en Nouvelle-Zélande non ça coupe du
monde attention les néo-zélandaises qui
sont probablement favorites sur leur
terre
en tout cas ce sera je sais pas si tu
suis un petit peu moi je regarderai
peut-être mais le 5 le 5 novembre c'est
quel jour c'est samedi
à 7h30 du matin
franchement c'est sympa c'est un peu
moins il y a un peu moins d'impact que
chez les hommes et un peu plus de jeux
de mouvement
c'est un très beau sport je vous
recommande d'y jeter un œil
si vous n'avez pas si vous n'avez pas
l'habitude c'est
vrai non ça joue bien ça joue bien et
l'équipe de France joue bien
jeux de mouvement ouais c'est plus un
jeu de mouvement
pas un jeu de
quoi c'est plus un jeu de contournement
c'est ce qu'ils essayent de faire en
rechangeant les règles chez les hommes
aussi mais chez les femmes il y a plus
de contournement quand même
mais il faut en baisser OK
c'est assez symétrique comme position
quand même
est-ce que tu peux pas cliquer un
cavalier E4 et retrouver la symétrie
complète genre ça et tu cliques
et tu cliques clic clic
la chance tu vas faire C5 et économiser
un tempo quand même
et ouais
peut-être le mettre quelque part en haut
à droite et on nous dit cette vie
féminin faut mélanger en fait en avant
là si les matchs duraient 6h je
regarderai pas un seul match en fait le
sport ne m'intéresserait pas
mais c'est cool
bah samedi je suis pas bien enfin je te
le dis tout de suite
il y a tout en fait samedi c'est
trop en fait
trop le même jour quoi
mettre le score ici en fait
ça réfléchitaro
[Musique]
ça réfléchit ça réfléchit
à quel moment
je mettais le score il y a peut-être eu
des coups parce que j'étais concentré
sur le score ils disent que c'est pas à
jour
oh il a ok en fait
et il y a eu fouet donc il peut
retrouver la symétrie en réalité
c'est quoi les deux autres test match ça
sera
Angleterre Argentine et Irlande Afrique
du Sud
oui en fait et ça c'est à 18h enfin bon
tu vois c'est je suis vraiment pas bien
bon écoute on pourra pendant les parties
là du truc on pourra un peu suivre le
rugby c'est pas grave c'est pas un peu
en fait c'est que moi je vais je vais
mettre mon setup là quand même bah
disons que France Australie si tu veux
entre entre France Australie ou Raja bof
ça me séviant
oui
un même entre Carlson Naka et François
Australie en fait mais là d'autant plus
mais on a toujours pas les dates du
Championnat du Monde d'échec
[Musique]
mais on sait pas où non plus en fait on
sait rien
on sait pas où non je crois qu'en fait
nepo ça n'intéresse pas du tout d'aller
jouer en Chine parce que les Chinois
arrêtaient disposés à plus ou moins
organisé quand même le tournoi du coup
enfin je comprends pas en fait c'est
peut-être enfin je sais pas pourquoi ça
marche pas c'est quand même logique de
faire le truc dans le pays d'un des deux
enfin
surtout je crois que ça coûte 7 millions
la blague quoi donc faut quand même
trouver un pays assez fou pour te sentir
cette mignon pour organiser ça bon tu en
trouvant un coup de chance
en Arabie Saoudite en au
Qatar ou quelque chose comme ça non
peut-être enfin du coup si c'est pas en
Chine je sais pas qui ça peut pas être
en Russie non plus j'imagine donc
mais en fait je trouve que justement
dites moi dans le chat si vous pensez
que j'ai tort mais ça me paraît logique
pour un événement qui est censé être
majeur quand même de ton sport quand
c'est une finale de championnat du monde
que ça joue dans le pays d'un des deux
joueurs
bon ça pas forcément mais non mais genre
c'est pas obligatoire mais genre il y a
une logique quand même mais ça peut
enfin en fait en gros faut trouver
quelqu'un qui soit intéressé pour
l'organiser déjà ah mais globalement par
exemple
j'ai l'impression que dans tous un peu
comme ça quand organise à la fin les
combats de boxe les machins et tous les
promoteurs c'est toujours dans le pays
dans des deux boxeurs quasiment ouais ou
souvent ça Vegas ou quoi mais dans une
ville je veux dire ou alors tu as un
endroit
mythique de ton sport ou ça se joue tout
le temps mais là aux échecs comme il y a
pas dans 3 mythiques
pas forcément ben je vois pas pourquoi
tu refuses en fait c'est un sponsor je
vois pas pourquoi tu le joueur a le
droit de refuser je pense le genre ne
rien dire
il faut que ce soit neutre ouais enfin
bon tu demandes quand même 7 millions de
bah enfin
organisé quoi
si demain je te file un chèque de 3
millions et demi et que tu me dis bon
non
ou alors ça doit être dans un endroit
mythique fabriqué avec là je suis
d'accord ça peut mais bon
faut que ça soit en terrain neutre
jamais à domicile
ça dépend
[Musique]
pas le truc c'est que déjà ce qui serait
logique c'est que ce soit décidé avant
qu'il y ait le matin
c'est noté l'endroit et qui que ce soit
les joueurs quoi
mais bon
après si il se trouve qu'il y a un mec
qui est à domicile bah il est à domicile
non mais surtout qu'aux échecs ça va
quoi enfin il va pas y avoir de plus
il y a pas le public qui va
qui va chanter pendant le match et te
mettre la pression
aussi favoriser du coup il est pas là
enfin les autres sont pas là à se
plaindre en disant oui j'aurais pas les
candidats en Russie enfin
et puis par contre tu as le droit d'y
aller en avance et t'adapter
l'environnement et compagnie enfin tu
peux venir avec ton cuisinier si tu as
envie de de manger des trucs à toi et
que tu aimes pas la cuisine locale et
compagnie c'est pas ça ça va tu finir
ton staff tes médecins tes trucs si tu
veux ouais non je suis
mais c'est quand même étonnant enfin je
sais pas mais c'est quand même flippant
dans un sport que la Fédération arrive
même pas organisée son match Championnat
du Monde correctement
non après ça va ça se trouve une époque
va finir par accepter mais je crois
qu'il était pas du tout chaud l'idée les
gens chinois dans tout cas quoi
tu as même pas les dates de ton
Championnat du Monde 5 mois à l'avant
c'est un je sais pas comment dire mais
ça c'était terrible
majeur c'est juste le seul événement en
route ta discipline quoi c'est le seul
événement tu as discipline ouais très
claire vu que pour ça en fait
et tu arrives même pas à l'organiser
quoi c'est
mais j'ai l'impression que que le
affaire à suivre mais j'ai l'impression
que que l'affaire animal va laisser des
traces je crois qu'il y a déjà un
premier pas vers ça c'est que bah tu
vois c'est signe que fil qui se
sponsorise les échecs américains depuis
des années à hauteur de plusieurs
millions par an ouais et là je suis très
étonné qu'elle a champion du monde
d'échecs par équipe il y a pas un joueur
américain du top qui a accepté de jouer
une question d'argent c'est qu'ils sont
beaucoup moins payés qu'avant sinon ils
vont jouer
et je me sens
et je me demande
si ça a pas une connexion enfin je
m'inquiète pour les échecs américains
parce que si que field imagine tu as
envoyé pour sur 6 7 ans 30-40 millions
de balles les mecs sur les tons que tu
as fait en refusant de jouer en faisant
des accusations diffamatoires et tu te
rends peut-être compte que tu as des
joueurs du top niveau de ton pays qui
triche
et peut-être pas que Niman tu vois tu
peux te poser des questions sur d'autres
aussi
tu dois pas être bien
bah oui c'était passionné et puis bah je
sais pas tu files plein de frics
jeter ouais enfin honnêtement je sais
pas là c'est supposition que j'ai
supposition mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a peut-être de l'eau dans le gaz
possible j'ai aucune info dessus mais
moi non plus mais c'est juste
racine que file je serais très énervé
mais les signaux tu vois le j'attendais
de voir l'équipe des États-Unis qui
sortirait pour ce tournoi là pour me
faire un premier avis sur tu vois j'y
pensais mais je me dis bon c'est pas du
tout rien dit ok c'est pas un signal
super positif après avoir après ça peut
aussi être qu'ils en ont rien à faire de
ce tournoi qui vaut rien quoi enfin
c'est un truc créé toutes pièces cette
année qui a aucune légitimité en soi
enfin tu vois ce que je veux dire ouais
mais avant ils envoient
non non mais bien sûr enfin tu peux
aussi dire bon bah je vais aller prendre
le truc c'est un titre c'est comme ça
mais en soi c'est rien quoi enfin c'est
oui bien sûr
tu peux aussi te dire oui bon on va pas
jouer ce truc on s'en fiche on en a déjà
fait des frais aller aux Olympiades
assis à ça bon on ira jouer les vrais
compétitions oui mais bon ils ont quand
même l'habitude de faire des frais pour
rien partout donc non non
je me pose des questions
ça peut poser question je suis d'accord
en fait ça peut poser des questions
ouais franchement à sa place je sais pas
là vous vous aussi les amis discute un
peu un peu échec au-delà de la position
mais
la situation est le seul enfin le seul
tu es le plus gros mécène des échecs
depuis longtemps tu organisé tournoi tu
payes la fête de tout le monde tu fais
gagner un pognon de malade pour
reprendre une expression bien cher
à plein de gens et les mecs te chie
ouvertement dessus
c'est un moment ou bon oui vous êtes
bien gentil mais ça va 5 minutes ouais
puis tu peux faire autre chose que des
échecs tu as envie d'être ton argent
ouais ouais ça peut ça peut
c'est des suppositions il y en a qui
c'est pas lui qui dépend des échecs
les ordinateurs le faisaient à perte
c'était c'est du mécénature ouais c'est
c'est comme un c'est des dons en quelque
sorte et c'est vrai quand tu donnes de
l'argent autant d'argent à un petit
milieu et que les mecs te chie dessus
comme ça franchement enfin moi je me
posais la question honnêtement je me dis
tiens est-ce que ça va est-ce que ça va
tenir est-ce qu'il va cuite
ou pas voilà je suis dans
l'interrogation et comme je disais voilà
je partage avec vous ce
cette équipe des États-Unis qui est
peut-être un signal alors là peut-être
on est on est dans de la théorie semi
cuite mais oui c'est vrai que même sans
envoyer l'équipe type tu peux avoir une
équipe hybride
mijuni tu envoi Hikaru et je sais pas
qui quoi Dominguez par exemple tu vois
enfin tu mets pas tu as pas encore là tu
as pas chaud ok c'est pas grave mais là
tu as vraiment personne
introuvable parce que ça a l'air de
fermer
bah d'ailleurs ça gagne pas enfin
non non
on peut pas tout prendre parce qu'on est
clou à la fin
mais on a peut-être qui est G7 échec
intermédiaire
[Musique]
c'est pas clair ça c'est très compliqué
en fait juste pour venir sur ce truc
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a aucune
équipe et on va l'équipe max quoi
non non il y a pas d'équipe c'est
l'équipe qui essaye en fait personne
prend trop ça au Méga sérieux quoi j'ai
envie de dire
pas tout le monde sera bien content de
gagner et de faire ça comme dessus si
jamais ça se passe bien mais en soi
qui remplit merci avec Trackmania quand
ça serait pas possible aux échecs le
spectacle avant tout ben aux échecs on
pourrait remplir des grandes salles
franchement de la sale bâtard là très
très franchement pour avoir vu avec la
billetterie etc et les les réactions
qu'il y a eu on remplissait 500 600
personnes sans aucun problème et sans
communication hors de hors de mon stream
donc demain
tu aurais un organisateur comme signes
que field ou en promoteur d'événements
qui nous contacteraient pour faire un
truc d'échec pour un pour un final de
championnat du monde ou truc comme ça on
n'est pas 16 10 dans la salle on peut
[Musique]
grande salle surtout que là c'est
gratuit c'est il y a même pas de de de
prix d'entrée moi nous on pouvait
remplir quelque chose de payant en fait
mais les échecs en plus comme d'habitude
les salles sont gratuites ouais les deux
trois mille personnes sur Paris on les
remplis
c'est quasi sûr en fait oui enfin je
sais pas combien mais en tout cas 500
entre 500 et 1000 c'est 100% sûr en tout
cas ce que j'ai vu oui ce battle en 15
minutes c'était rempli quoi ouais donc
bon budget de communication c'est quand
généralement pour pour les grands
tournois ils ont des quand même des
budgets importants comme
en France tu mets à lire ça qualifié
d'office au tournoi tu fais
tu fais un peu de comme à droite à
gauche tu demandes à quelques streamers
d'en parler est un petit budget
là dessus tu vois c'est c'est c'est
c'est vite fait
donc nous on pourrait le faire ouais
mais bon
et on te ferait pas chier de faire des
sales scandales
ça dépend partie longue pas sûr ah bah
si on le fait on va aussi faire ce sera
pas des parties donc ouais on va aussi
faire les formats NicOx quand même
on te ferait quand même des formes un
petit peu je pense on ferait les formats
en fait
moi pourquoi pas voir je sais pas trop
mais oui le format D7 ça m'intéresse
cricore Mathieu c'était vraiment
intéressant je passe à regarder un petit
peu non je sais pas enfin quand je vais
arriver c'était déjà fini en fait
les interviews de fin de partie
de match avec les prépas et machin
ça c'est parti dans cette variante on va
on va voir on va voir la résultante mais
mon fou prend roi des 7 tours G8 ça peut
être hyper dangereux pour les blancs
ouais il va essayer de mettre son rangés
deux mais en F2 mes meilleurs F2 tu as
des cages et
ouais enfin on se dit que c'est la plus
agréable pour les Noirs c'est c'est un
classique des échecs il faut que le
reposer favorise l'attaque et bah c'est
plutôt les noirs qui ont l'attaque avec
le roi qui va être en D7 plutôt bien à
l'abri et les tours qui coulissent sur
la colonne g peut-être H5 H4 qui part le
cavalier qui arrive etc c'est facile à
jouer donc voilà mieux pour les Noirs
après à quel point mieux etc ça bon on
verra mais
ouais c'est c'est une époque qui fait
une bonne une bonne deuxième partie
ok oui
ça peut aller très très vite ça
champion du monde aux échecs voilà tu en
as un principal c'est le c'est la
cadence classique le match cette année
ça devrait être népo qu'onding ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure on sait pas quand
c'est ni rien
et après alors il y en a deux autres
cadences en rapide et en blitz donc ça
sera fin décembre ça
et là ils nous font ça là du monde de
c'est nouveau mais pourquoi pas mais
pareil alors du coup ça a pas du tout la
même valeur
le champion du monde 1960 c'est un peu
en mode exhibition comme on a dit quoi
qui sont là la plupart sont qualifiés
sur Internet et noix de cartes tu as des
trucs enfin ça fait pas super officiel
etc même si ça sera un vrai titre mais
c'est encore un peu les babuciements
pour pour voilà c'est pas un format
super sérieux
disons à part le titre en classique il y
a pas de vrai circuit fait pour quoi
a commencé à menacer ton projet
mais peut-être qu'il va faire le 4 juste
à temps pour fermer cette diagonale
[Musique]
le match est quasi hier de zéro c'est
ouais mais bon en même temps il faut
qu'il joue enfin si il joue pas cette
partie là dans ce genre de position
alors là il a la position pour gagner
bien sûr mais
une position pas facile mais mais il
sait que si réussi à la faire tourner en
sa faveur il gagne le match quoi
quasiment non mais bien joué parce que
il tue un peu le fouet
3 du coup et
[Musique]
qui va arriver
en tout cas ça réfléchit 13 minutes
contre 11
important
mais
je sais pas trop ce qu'on veut avec les
noirs
si on prend 4 puis on prend fou prank et
G5 je crois un truc comme ça
j'espère que ça mais non
OK
[Musique]
tu arrives à fermer avec avec les Blancs
de justesse
ok j'avais pas pensé du tout à l'idée
du sens pour essayer tout ouvrir mais là
c'est double tranchant parce que le roi
noir du coup devient faible également
on a les coûts qui sont pas encore
arrivés je vais remettre le
5 fe dans ma C3
que les blancs vont maintenir ce blocus
sur 4 le 7 pourra pas attaquer son H1 et
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que c'est foutu en
fait
bon vous touchez pas ça peut tourner
genre de position c'est bizarre parce
que tu peux rajouter un petit F4 qui
revient mettre de l'huile sur le feu tu
peux peut-être trouver des idées mais
[Musique]
actuellement tu as un pion de moins et
tu as toutes les pièces sur le roi et tu
as pas de maths donc peut-être c'est
juste que tu te manque une pièce quoi
c'est compliqué
donc
quasi en tout cas c'est un peu moins
pliant 960 qu'en échec classique mais
ouais c'est proche de plier
c'est très proche
là si ça se trouve faut faire peut-être
que les Blancs je sais pas
tu bouffes la tour il y a F2 mais bon je
crois qu'il y a juste au 4 et que
du coup ça se trouve à Paris quoi c'est
un peu chiant
à tes bras avoir un coup libre là pour
jeter ton attaque sans me casser la tête
à réfléchir et en fait il y a déjà des
menaces blanches
en fait on attaque à le bas de l'aile
complexe
avec ce serait pas idiot d'avoir un
match de championnats du monde sur les
14 parties deux ou quatre parties en 960
pourquoi pas en fait moi je sais pas
mais oui ça éviterait de se prendre
14 parties 14 prépas
pour le public c'est vrai que ce serait
sympa de
varier un peu les plaisirs
non mais tu peux vraiment faire un titre
ultime
avec du blé une journée bleed une
journée rapide une journée 960 et
mais quatre jours de classique quatre
jours je veux dire quatre parties quoi
si tu as envie un petit peu
ou pas enfin ça se réfléchit mais
[Musique]
en 1960 en fait
juste aux échecs normaux c'est en fait
jamais le tour et là tu dois faire 960
j'avais le tour
là non c'est trop trop difficile
donc non après tu peux t'habituer à
jouer un peu à prendre des automatismes
avoir des meilleurs réflexes mais tu vas
jamais apprendre la théorie de 960
positions de départ différents
[Musique]
ça va être aussi compliqué que la
position de départ des échecs
intéressants plusieurs donner la
position de 960 genre 6 mois avant le
début du match
dans les échecs normaux
ouais mais du coup ce serait vraiment
intéressant
permettrait de voir une nouvelle théorie
[Musique]
se préparer c'est drôle quoi
ça va peut-être être
le chant du cygne
ok bon
après si pas six mois avec la position
tu perds l'intérêt du 960 oui et non
parce que en 6 mois ils auront pas le
temps de il y a tellement de coups
possible et de
c'est tu peux aussi ne pas leur donner
la position du tout tu tires au sort et
puis bah voilà le jour même c'est comme
ça
tu peux tout faire
mais je crois qu'il aime bien se
préparer pour être bien sûr
non mais juste en fait quelque part se
préparer c'est que tu enlèves
tu enlèves
tu es plus eux qui jouent quoi en fait
ouais actuellement avec les ordis ouais
c'est toujours le même le même débat
donc ils vont jouer au bout d'un moment
mais là au moins tu joues dès le premier
coup
je suis en train de me demander un truc
genre ça ça ça ça ça
c'est encore
[Musique]
ouais ça peut être joli ça
prise prise prise prise mais il va
l'avoir Naka c'est assez facile en fait
[Musique]
mais la ligne est mignonne
bon ça va il a pas trop mal géré il a
bien pris son temps pour trouver un truc
pas clair tant que spion F3
2 parce qu'il faut prendre le cadre d'un
problème 2 et cavalier F2 c'est comme
une concession
[Musique]
tu te fais taper quand même sur les deux
diagonales
et tu vois le roi il va revenir proche
du four
ma position est compliquée ici mais bon
les Blancs ont quand même un pion de
plus c'est le roi noir est peut-être pas
si bien d'ailleurs surtout F7 aurait fui
tu peux imposer l'adulte je pense
parce que toi
juste prise dans ma cheville
[Musique]
on se rapproche
si les Noirs réussissent pas à
déstabiliser le cavalier et que la dame
arrive pas à rentrer en jeu les blancs
vont être mieux oui
OK
en fait tu as peut-être juste pas de
coup avec les noirs pour améliorer
c'est chiant ça donne tire entre nulle
part je pense
3g2 puis on reprend H7
libérer la tour et je pense ça c'est
complètement fini en fait
[Musique]
du coup la dame elle serait attachée à
la défense de ses 7 et
c'est dette non
bah ça a pas l'air
qu'un jour tu prends des 6 c'est sur
tout reprendre
ça t'ouvre aussi ces trucs là
et ça t'ouvre aussi
ok c'est ça qui serait cloués pour le
moment quand même pour l'instant
[Musique]
plus difficile quelque part dans ces
trois bêtes et méchant enfin juste
[Musique]
tu as tout aussi pour mettre la dame en
F1
c'est comme ça qui peut être une option
tu as trois options intéressantes là
on dit car oui n'est pas favori bah
maintenant il est
bon le match c'est dur à dire parce que
ce sont les deux les deux jouent pas mal
quoi
après j'ai l'impression que c'est quand
même un jeu bien taillé pour lui
ouais
son défaut on va dire par rapport à
l'élite mondiale ce qui la moins le
temps de bosser et il joue toujours la
même ouverture donc il a plu un
répertoire très large donc il est très
attendu après il connaît bien son truc
berlinoise et compagnie il la joue pas
mal son grand bidame ou quoi il y a pas
de souci mais il a pas trop d'effets de
surprise et prendre l'avantage avec les
Blancs c'est dur pour lui et avec les
Noirs il peut se faire cibler ici ou là
dans quelques parties
bon bah là il y a pas toutes ces
histoires de prépa ou quoi c'est très
tactique en plus très vite donc ça
rentre très vite dans là où il est
excellent donc
en fait ça gomme c'est des faux enfin
son principal défaut on va dire et ça
accentue sa force donc c'est pas mal
pour lui
c'est vraiment le jeu parfait pour les
carreaux
ouais mais jouer
parce que Jordan C7
[Musique]
il est dans le dur Yann
ouais tu tiens un fil avec les mains
tu tiens même pas en réalité c'est
l'ordi qui tient mais tu tiens pas en
fait
OK
c'est bizarre mais leur dire Odon =
tu veux quoi en fait tu veux tout rêver
ouais mais après le truc c'est qu'est-ce
que tu joues avec les Blancs aussi
peut-être
parce que tu as aussi du mal à trouver
des coups
c'est sûr que tu penses que tu es
gagnant avec les Blancs
mais tu l'es pas la position est assez
ouf position est bizarre ouais tu as pas
de coup
parce que tu as pas le temps de faire H4
essayer de partir avec Laurent H3 tu
arrives pas
je suis roi G2 il y a des échec
probablement
on va voir s'il y a tout racheté
ou Pierre tu montes Laurent aussi
trois points 8 et c'est le cavalier il
perdent
c'est terminé mais il y a les il y a un
clouage découverte donc il a fait
tourage 8 bon roi des 7 c'est le seul
coup de de répéter parce que tu vas
récupérer les 5 minutes
parce que c'est trop dangereux comme
position
tu te dis vas-y
3 c'est 8 tours
avec les Noirs quand même
voilà c'est même sûr d'ailleurs
passé le roi en B7 dame B6 c'est à peu
près la même position et c'est toujours
très haut blanc sauf que le roi et n'est
plus vulnérable
qui serait mieux tout d'un coup
intéressant de voir comment il Caro va
se dépêtrer Fab
je pense qu'il va faire roisser 8
ces choses faites il récupère 5 minutes
je suis sûr que ça c'est vraiment faveur
des noirs
tu en penses quoi mon Fab ouais ouais
ces deux échecs ils n'auront pas servi à
grand chose
Yann qui revient complètement dans la
partie
non c'est quand même pas mal aussi
960 pour ça là que en fait il y a des
retournements dans les parties parce que
c'est moins schématique donc
le truc c'est que
ton truc dans l'ouverture tu es mieux on
sait six heures à l'avance qui va se
passer et on regarde pendant 6h le truc
annoncé et ça se passe comme prévu et
bon bah oui on savait mais on attend une
demi-heure avant qu'il joue son coup et
voilà
il y a un côté suspense
en fait la position elle tourne de
manière complètement inattendue et là il
carouille ici hein je peux te dire sur
la cam il hésite il arrive pas à jouer
son cou il y a de s'élever
regarde regarde hyper hyper hyper pied
c'est beau parce que les joueurs se
perdent aussi ce qu'on a pas l'habitude
à regarder
3D7 est nul c'est sûr qu'il a pensé
faire ça et ça y est il a compris tu
auras juste trois B7 tours achètes d'un
B6 il y a rien derrière
pourquoi le cahier peut pas mettre la
tour en échec alors il aimerait il
aimerait cheval Jolly Jumper mais il est
cloué
il faut qu'il trouve tout recettes
OK
ouais
tu repars avec 3G 2 d'accord
bon il a fait
ah ouais
il est très fort
dans votre tête le coup
peut-être une peau trop optimiste de pas
faire roi des 8
mais tout reste 5
c'est dégueu de seul coup
c'est quoi la ligne 3D 8
un seul coup
F6 d'un E3
et ça c'est nul genre ok mais je veux
bien le croire en fait si la dame est en
F7 c'est gagnant mais là ça dépend mais
attends c'est quoi du coup c'est ça
pour égalité D4 seul courroie
tu as pas le temps de regarder 8 ici
parce qu'il prend F6 d'accord il a fait
tout rêve 5 ok bon si la toux il mérite
d'être champion du monde du jeu je te
dis tout de suite
c'est extrêmement difficile
enfin tu bloques la dame à 7 ok mais tu
enlèves ton socle au cavalier
ouais c'est costaud après une fois que
tu l'as vu oui bon tu mais bon oui c'est
très dur même quand tu l'as vu tu es pas
trop sûr peut-être
non mais c'était à la position jusqu'à
dame 3 après la pièce de moins tu te dis
ok tu as réussi à faire de la magie
c'est faire perpette ouais ouais mais
bon autant hier tu vois il y a un truc
dur qu'il a pas joué là le cavalier
aussi des 8 F7 mais il y avait vraiment
une logique là c'est [ __ ] de dur ouais
mais c'est Hikaru que des coups de ouf
quoi bah il va avoir un il a des cartes
je crois qu'il a récupéré
c'est impressionnant
il a tout
spectaculaire quoi
spectaculaire incroyable
c'est assez incroyable
c'est fou d'avoir c'est extrêmement dur
quand même
c'est extrêmement dur je crois que Nevo
pas jouer il va peut-être faire un tour
F3 un truc comme ça je sais pas
c'est extrêmement dur
mais c'est sûr qu'il avait un roi des 8
je me pose la question moi en regardant
tu vois pourquoi pas
après on sait pas qui est mieux
[Musique]
il veut quoi
défendre son pion dire tu as pas de
menace d'ailleurs il le fait
tellement bien en fait dame D1 est à
plus de menaces
mais bon cela dit pas grand-chose non
plus
maintenant si tu te laisses prendre à
trois et qui revient tu vas être moins
bien aussi
quelle défense du carreau il est solide
il est très solide
Dame des trois
tours
je vais avoir
attendez trois peut-être
mais bon
[Musique]
j'en sais rien c'est trop compliqué
enfin
moi bon de me [ __ ]
[Musique]
qu'il a le choix il a tout droit aussi
peut-être mais bon
j'ai deux tours F2
il te manque cette dame en fait
tu mets le tour
[Musique]
peut-être même on peut faire
c'est juste pour défendre des quatre et
faire des preuves
tu peux
parler de faire roi des 8
aussi
bon c'est chaud
il y a trop de trucs en fait
il y a trop il y a que 3 minutes parce
que
tu souffles un peu mieux avec les Blancs
quand même tu as besoin de toutes les
pièces sont bien placées tout d'un coup
c'est dur à juger leur dit de
complètement gagnant au blanc mais
non mais
il manque une tour à l'attaque au nord
par rapport à tout à l'heure tu as plus
clouage
et dame trois recettes c'est pas mal je
trouve enfin visuellement ça m'a l'air
une amélioration pour les blancs quoi
ouais après si je te fais dame C6 que je
décale la tour
ah ouais non faut pas te laisser
toujours
même le truc qui propose cavalier F6
dame C6 qui a été 5 dames dessin
4 et sur Damas 2 tours 8
même ça en fait c'est même pas ça la
ligne
il a trouvé kf6 en tout cas
non mais ok
qui a été extrêmement bon dans cette
phase
juste plus fort en fait
ouais ouais
mais ça défendu le faire en face
il est juste plus fort il y a rien à
dire
il est juste maintenant meilleur
et c'est le tour prend le 3 du coup qui
était mauvais mais bon après
un streamer qui va un professionnel
exactement
est-ce que du coup on doit tenter ça
dame C6 tours B7 qui est des 5 va me
prendre des 500
alors attends il a commencé par créer
prendre des 5
échec
de tour C2
il veut
c'est pas con
il joue bien les deux
tout à l'heure
roi F3 dame D5 dame
il va prendre le roi G2 évidemment prend
des cinq ouais il va prendre nul c'est
nul Fab signé
[Musique]
trop compliqué il mène un zéro c'est
normal de faire nul aussi non c'est bien
pour le parti des deux
parties très très solide des deux hommes
on comprend pourquoi ils sont en finale
là c'est c'est pas le même niveau
que dans l'autre match ou Magnus est en
train de revenir
mais ça joue nettement mieux que que les
deux autres joueurs
bon là c'est une grosse partie
envoyer de part et d'autre c'était
précis
ouais c'était ça a été relativement
précis par rapport à la difficulté de la
position
car ça a perdu en demi- ouais contre
contre Yann et paumes
Détroit bon ça va pas ça ça peut pas
aller pour pour le joueur ouzbek
qui va s'incliner Fabien
c'est pas un coup
je reprends
C6 te faire une fourchette si tu enlève
6 on le sait et si tu recules je viens
quand même et
tout doit marcher là mais bon je sais
pas toi j'ai pas mon pion F5 à la fin
bien joué
bien joué icaru et Yann c'est ce qu'on
attend d'une finale de championnat du
monde quand même et là le niveau est au
rendez-vous
ils ont été très bons
tu aurais pu tourner d'un côté ou de
l'autre
la roue tourne aurait pu tourner
très bien joué
ça va abandonner la côté Nadir Beck il
pourra pas défendre le pion B7 est trop
fort ma nièce qui va égaliser
il n'y a plus de défense là
surtout C8 il veut quoi
sans oublier une
il abandonne pas non plus de manière
je comprends pas trop en fait c'est
chose qu'on va quand même apprendre à
l'école d'échec
d'abandonner correctement
est-ce que c'est pas le moment de notre
pause là parce qu'il va y avoir une
attente quand même assez assez longue
je vais faire une petite pause et on se
retrouve
exactement c'est bien vu ça
c'est bien vu Fab
on va laisser le score comme ça on va le
mettre
[Musique]
parce que je crois que c'est 18 enfin
même je pense que la position elle est
annoncée à 30 ça joue à 45
je pense on revient à 30 ok ça roule
tout à l'heure
on est revenu même un peu trop tôt parce
que il y a r en fait
c'est ouais mais cette pause tu vois
j'étais en train de décrire un copain je
disais en fait c'est pas possible d'être
elle pose
trop en fait tu peux pas faire
non mais 6h c'est trop long enfin je
sais pas 6h c'est beaucoup de temps en
fait non mais justement en fait le la
rigueur le match entre la deuxième place
pourra servir à ça ce qu'il fasse des
Blitz pendant ce temps quoi
qu'il en soit juste tu cliques enfin on
est là pour cliquer en fait de toute
façon des joueurs ils sont pas à fond là
dire c'est pas un événement majeur d'un
titre de je sais pas quoi franchement je
pense maquenouille
si tu leur demandes ah non mais oui bah
oui non mais c'est parce que c'est pas
enfin
non mais il faut avoir un spectacle un
concert je sais pas moi des trucs quoi
enfin il pourrait se passer un truc
pour la pause je suis d'accord bah ouais
enfin je sais pas quoi
tu aurais pas une chanteuse qui vient un
petit concert qui part machin
pourquoi pas la montagne tu fais
soulever des cailloux je sais pas un
truc
je suis d'accord avec toi
voilà peut-être que il fait ça
et en fait pendant qu'il fait ça un
moment donné tu as des petites pausettes
ou tu as les joueurs qui jouent les
petits coups
tu vois la rigueur
tu pourrais non
franchement c'est pas mal je trouve ça
là on tient un concept entre le gars qui
se lève les cailloux tananéco énervé qui
vient de faire des petites pauses où il
joue deux trois coups d'échecs
une sorte de chasse boxing améliorée
quoi
complètement amélioré ouais
ça ce serait beau
après c'est suggestions
ouais mais c'est
ça fait combien d'événements qu'on
commande comme ça ou tu regardes et tu
dis c'est pas possible
c'est tout le temps possible en fait si
tu dis à chaque fois c'est pas possible
on se fait chier quand même mais encore
que tu vois par la nature du jeu et tout
au moins pour les personnes d'un
spectacle
ça te fait pas la petite nul de merde
dans une position assise quoi
pendant 8 heures
quand même quoi
bah ça me manque l'enrobage quoi ouais
le contenu est pas mal mais alors ton ah
bah on va pas réfléchir la position
nel
tu te fais un peu enrobade quoi
tu suis un petit peu quoi
en C1 j'imagine ce que je vois tu as le
gros plan de l'échiquier non non pas
encore
ah tu veux dire ouais ok
comme d'hab demander un tour bien c'est
ça
[Musique]
alors je peux pas défendu
et je dois défendre
[Musique]
bon c'est peut-être quand même une
position on peut jouer des quatre quoi
ça peut
ça
bon ça va être des quatre des cinq
je me disais peut-être un petit Dame des
trois
et peut-être qu'on peut faire notre
petit C4
ou 4
la dame
je peux pas faire
je perds des quatre
est-ce que on va la voir sur les chic et
on peut bouger pas encore
pas encore Fab
iennes mais alors après il faut que tu
saches altaryan que les la position des
pions aussi et au hasard
en 960
c'est un truc que peu de gens savent
enfin
le pion g peut se retrouver en dés et
inversement
et ça c'est vrai que c'est peu c'est peu
dit Fab
ne le dis pas assez parce qu'on te parle
vraiment que des pièces
le foot quasiment même se retrouver sur
une case danse ça peut arriver que les
pousses intervertissent aussi ouais
quelle différence ben la différence est
grande c'est que si tu veux jouer G4 si
le pion G est s'était retrouvé en e donc
tu te retrouves à faire tu peux tromper
de pion quoi
c'est quand même assez dérangeant
et puis on sent des bouts au lait c'est
ça il joue un peu moins bien à un moment
donné tu dis option d'avancer deux cas
il dit oui je suis un petit peu fatigué
je connais pas très bien cette colonne
bon et
il peut faire un mauvais match quoi il
veut pas manger en diagonale parce qu'il
a jamais mangé de pion h de sa vie et tu
peux
tu peux perdre là-dessus
je veux des détails
il y a une faute sur quoi
il y a une faute sur le logo
en bas je sais pas j'ai pas de j'ai pas
de refaire
[Musique]
j'ai pas la ref
ais
en fait c'est fait exprès je crois
logo du temps ah non je crois que c'est
fait exprès
que les LED soit à l'envers en fait
c'est le
random donc justement
vous avez pas compris on peut avoir deux
fous sur case non ah non ça tu peux pas
mais tu peux changer tu peux changer ton
foot ton foot casseurs peut devenir ton
foot casse blanche
bah là derrière la position qu'on voit
j'ai l'impression que c'est le fou F1
qui est passé en E1
donc
ils ont
ils ont changé de couleur quoi
non le logo est sympa ouais
j'hésite pour le premier coup
moi j'aurais fait des quattro quand même
[Musique]
pourquoi pourquoi pas en même temps tu
me diras
en fait
donc
une catalane après tu aurais pour ces
quatre machins enfin je suis très bien
en fait
madame quelque part
je vais te faire petit rock c'est 4 en
premier
pourquoi pas
tu sais non
non
c'est important
sinon tu t'emmerdes pas tu fais F4
des 5 D4 3 tu fais un genre de stone
wall tu ressors le fou en H4 tu es le
cavalier en E5 tu as le choix qui est
bien et tu joues pour C4 en fait
tu peux en refaire ça aussi
de base mais voilà tu fais 4 dessins
[Musique]
étape page 3 facile parce que tu es
Chloé 4
mais F4 pourquoi pas en fait d'ailleurs
mais bon on s'en fout
ouais quand même pour la structure
je m'en fous
[Musique]
c'est quand même pas con
en plus il fait f4d5 cavaliers F3 quand
tu vas jouer E6 j'aurais vraiment fou H4
qui peut être chiant tu vas mettre le
Cavaillon F6 mais là je pourrais jouer
des 4 3 et jouer à mon Stone
wall j'ai le fout bien le truc c'est
qu'il faut un pour un genre de Londres
comme ça Aston ou lisant j'ai quand même
quasiment toutes les pièces bien placées
j'ai le fout déjà sur B1 qui est bien je
vais tomber il est dans la chambre
je suis quand même bien en fait je suis
heureux
G6 après l'ordi
que des cartes c'est vraiment un coup de
merde
non c'est pas possible
[Musique]
je m'en fous on va y arriver
pas du tout
non
pas de problème
et il propose quoi ce conscient
on peut pas lui
OK
il est très heureux de ça
[Musique]
ok que ça ce soit aussi bien genre même
C6 il fait quoi le 4 en fait et il te
dit que ça tu es très bien
en fait F5 F4 a l'air d'être le main
les C4
en fait
j'imagine mais bon
[Musique]
je sais pas moi
ma F4 après j'ai trouvé quand même mais
pas pour la bonne raison
mais une vraie logique à F4
beaucoup de choses quand même
bon quand même quoi qu'on dise l'ordi on
va voir ce que fait
c'était directement une grimace de la
part du carreau
même si on a vu que c'était pas
forcément
la panacée dans ce mode de jeu c'est
quand même mieux bah ouais
tu joues le premier coup
je pense c'est les trois coups allez ça
applaudit une nouvelle fois
E4
on a vu que des 5 c'était pas bon mais
il le fait
ils ont rien compris en fait
[Musique]
c'était faute c'est quoi du coup sur le
coup
on a pas regardé
il veut pas dire le truc
ça faisait partie des bons coups
j'ai 5 pas mauvais
et là c'était pas c'était Caval F6
peut-être
non ça c'était bien pour les blancs non
mais c'est dames
OK
ils ont fait quoi les autres par
curiosité
du coup ça retombe un peu dans un truc
[Musique]
complexe comme position
très complexe
il va mettre le fond en F2 voir les deux
flous bien braquer
pas mal
on donne ici il veut fous j'imagine
éventuellement il peut avoir des grands
rocks
est-ce que dam F3 c'est si mal
en fait je comprends un truc con à la F3
c'est que tu t'enlèves les cases de
recul du fou mais bon
et tu vas te garder les deux rock pour
le moment
je pense
ouais
ça reste en l'air mais bon
je peux pas le laisser faire grand-père
parce qu'en fait à vrai dire s'il est
blanc faut prendre ces 6 dames français
6 et grand rock j'ai bien envie de faire
petit rock
cette fois-ci
et j'ai la tour aussi
et j'ai le cavalier aussi qui est bien
fait j'ai l'impression que je suis très
bien en agencé pour taper la dame
un peu comme dans un dragon
tu as quand même les pièces pas mal
placées
un peu différent du dragon mais quand
même
j'ai l'impression que je crache du feu à
fond
[Musique]
le théorème des fous toujours
j'ai l'impression que je suis bien sorti
ouais non franchement ça va ils ont pas
pris
quelques tempos sur le fou
et
naturellement naturellement
OK
question c'est comment tu rats ici
avec les Blancs alors plus partie pour
du Grand rock mais bon un petit fouet on
sera vite arrivé quand même
si tu veux attendre
on peut être un peu temporiser un coup
éventuellement
est-ce que c'est
ça à quoi on ne laisse pas je le mettrai
à quatre je laisse ton truc en un
je te ferai peut-être fou F2 petit rock
après ces trois qui a essayé de
ça
mais c'est beau
tu sues avec les Blancs
petit rock
grand rock j'y crois pas
mais bon c'est un coup quand même grand
rock
et qui défait F2 cavaliers
il me laisse pas faire
il le fait
je crois que ça a su parce que grand
petit rock
donc
c'est une position plus
cela c'est la plus normale de tout non
qu'on ait vu là c'est vraiment
dans la partie d'avance c'est normal en
fait
quasiment qui a été 7 OK
il veut 5
je sais pas
je sais pas exactement ce qu'il veut
peut-être B6 juste aussi
sur une case pour le fou
un truc comme ça
je me questionne mais ouais
et E5 à ce moment-là peut-être
[Musique]
sur
un truc direct et BD4 ou des 5 C4
pour choper le fou
il y a une logique
on a peur de [ __ ]
les deux positions se ressemblent
absolument pas
ok juste par curiosité
intellectuels
qui se ressemblent dans les deux parties
là ils sont partis dans deux directions
opposées
contre sens
OK
le nombre de fois qu'on a dit ça ce
weekend
à la sortie d'ouverture c'est réellement
pas rare tu te retrouves vite mal avec
les Blancs que tu puisses te retrouver
vite mal
il y a que tu sois obligé de trouver un
coup quoi
le prix d'un coup
puis une semaine j'ai pas vu avant trop
ce qu'il faisait mais bon jamais de 3-0
à
c'est pas mal
et là franchement pour l'instant
aujourd'hui c'est bien
il a les coups
sauve le fou là et B5 dame 6
parce que c'est le petit jeu tactique
maintenant
et ça ne fait que commencer
sur le tout
et je veux dire au pire c'est un peu
déstructures de ce qu'on dit car au
canne et compagnie sur blanc tu dises
l'ouverture j'ai l'impression d'avoir
fait la meilleure version de ma vie
j'en ai absolument rien à [ __ ] de la
paire de fou tu fais si ce système là
quoi ah bah oui ah bah oui non mais en
plus
j'allais dire je sais que j'ai 4 5 aussi
mais là où il fait ci évidemment j'en ai
absolument rien à [ __ ] c'est si ce
petit rock je sais pas ce que je fais
hein
4 je t'emmerde son cavalier je t'emmerde
ton pion enfin tu as même pas mis ton
pion des gars voilà pour moi c'est là je
suis dans un révélé
c'est une scandinave plus plus plus là
[Musique]
il peut être très heureux
c'est très chaud
en fait c'est vraiment une Candy qui a
bien tourné Fab
tu as bien repéré le truc
barre de fou oui bah qui mais bon je
suis au foot casse blanche j'ai tous les
pions sur casse blanche attention
musée des musées
ça peut être dur
malheureusement dans ce genre de
position c'est pas le côté positif du
module qu'on a
c'est blanc grand rock bah les blancs
rock
B5 j'en sais rien moi
tout rebondir
je sais pas trop ce qu'on est censé
faire avec les Blancs c'est c'est assez
chiant
c'est extrêmement chiant
c'est quasi catastrophe
en fait il leur manque des temps quoi
enfin ça peut aller si tu as pu mettre
le roi ou je sais pas quoi mais tu as
pas
ça ressemble c'est une scandale avec
quatre temps d'avance pour les noirs
on va être même le pion à 7 qui ont
l'air certaines variantes c'est pas
grave
ok pas de bête mais je veux dire après
bon ben ouais
regarde les fous enfin je regarde les
fous et je dis que les morceaux murs en
fait
il a fait trois
bah 5 ah il veut 5 puis on prend
cavalier prend fousser 5 mais 3
direct
ça peut pas être ça
c'est pas con évidemment mais c'est trop
en fait
les prend et
et qui se dit que des quatre arrivent et
que bon bah c'est pas ouf mais c'est la
vie quoi
je préfère le nom mais bon
un peu plus faible mais tu as le centre
non c'est pas terrible enfin je serais
pas content d'avoir ça avec les blancs
mais bon qu'est-ce que
[Musique]
tu es d'accord avec toi
j'ai mis la petite barre d'évaluation
[Musique]
ok peut-être
ce que je vais être là tu peux pas
prendre il faut prendre mais
si je fais tourner feu 8
il faut prendre
c'est pas des chèques à cause de ce qui
est B3
et tour à 8
en fait il veut prendre et puis avoir
[Musique]
regarde tu menaces oui donc
si tu prends
je sais pas mais bon
au pire tu auras 8 hein
ça
va peut-être y'a rien je veux dire mais
je sais pas ça a l'air tendu ça
c'est les noirs qui ont initiative après
en train de se faire écraser par le bide
en tout cas n'est pas ça on le reconnaît
il est encore enlevé le bouchon de la
bouteille d'eau
mais il a une consommation de caféine
n'est pas qui est impressionnante
ce qui a quand même beaucoup de café non
dans le coca aussi
ou c'est moi qui délire
enfin je sais pas trop les doses mais il
y en a ouais ça c'est sûr
et moi ils prennent les chiquer ou la
table et qu'il a renversent sur
quelqu'un en fait quand un joueur de
catcheur quoi
vous serez beaucoup il te prend
l'échiquier il te le défonce sur la
gueule quoi c'est quand il est vraiment
comme les combats de catch quand ils
prennent les sièges et qui se tapent
dessus quoi
mais ouais bon il a repris son rythme de
croisière je t'aime pour
ah bah là il est dans son dans son
élément
il est complètement dans son élément il
a le coca tu renverses le coca sur la
gueule
j'aurais bien avoir un truc un peu une
dinguerie tu vois pas un gars qui enlève
une croix sur les chiots ou quoi mais
genre quoi
je ne comprends rien c'est ko qui
remplace dingly rain qui remplace
lui-même Carlson ah non là du monde de
960 en fait ça a aucun rapport
c'est pour ça qu'on est pour lui
il nous représente Fab
sur tout le monde surtout toi 200%
ça ne joueur fétiches
si on prend des quatre qui prend au feu
8 il fait plaisir
prend le plan de l'ordi j'adore dame
fuite dame G7
[Rires]
parce que tu as que un fou qui regarde
là-bas donc tu dois le la coupler quoi
alors c'est beau petit rat qui a tout
reprend un trois prises et G4 il faut
prendre des cadres BAM
hé c'est bien joué de la part de Yann
du coup il revient
je pensais
même plus petit rock
ouais mais en fait c'est logique
et
en fait tu peux l'avoir dans mes fuites
parce que cavalier c'est 5 grands rock
tada en fait tu la mets naturellement
peut-être en fuite bah parce que c'est
vrai qu'elle a pas enfin sinon l'Iran C7
en cas normal mais bon pareil
[Musique]
après tout d'un coup tu penses à Dame G7
en fait il faut vouloir casser 5 il y a
eu 6 dans ma fuite autour des 8
elle est pas si mal dans ces trucs enfin
en plus elle peut revenir vers B4 à 3
aussi
pièce tu sais pas où la mettre en fait
il y a trop de colonne vertes et les
chiante donc je vais lui trouver une
petite tanière et
fuite ça peut faire le taf ou c'est ça
quoi enfin c'est ça les deux cases qu'on
peut penser quoi
ça c'est une tanière de renard je crois
en fait c'est enfin ils font rien c'est
juste ils sont ensemble non oh bah la
tanière c'est un peu ta maison quoi
c'est
là tu fais des petits trous là tu te
caches un peu dedans c'est loups ils
font mais ils font des petits trous tu
fais des petits trous quoi
il creuse des trous
et il se couche dedans
c'est magnifique en fait
ça peut des troglodites
c'est un abri souterrain de certains
mammifères sauvages naturels ou quelque
peu aménagés mais non entièrement creusé
par opposition au Terrier ah donc c'est
vraiment une tanière quoi il est pas
complètement un peu au hasard quoi
alors que j'ai 7 ce serait ce serait
plutôt le le terrier quoi
je l'ai quand même plus plus préparé le
G7 non plus
ouais les blaireaux aussi mais les
blaireaux et je crois qu'ils
construisent des trucs de dingue
et les castors pourquoi ils font des
barrages en fait
alors eux ouais je sais plus ou moins en
fait ils sont très heureux c'est hyper
malin c'est qu'en fait tu te crées un
truc sur l'eau alors tu dans leur
barrage le barrage est cassant tu peux
que rentrer par de manière sous-marine
donc du coup les cons qui peuvent pas
aller sous l'eau bah ils peuvent jamais
venir dans ton déjà
type les poissons ils peuvent jamais
venir en fait non plus en fait tu fermes
tout le monde eh regarde il faut plonger
pour venir après tu es chez moi du coup
si tu peux pas plonger tu peux pas venir
et si tu es dans l'eau ben tu peux pas
venir non plus
on faut un plongeur un mammifère
plongeur
plongeur qui peut venir te faire chier
mais bon
quand même beaucoup de problèmes agir un
dauphin qui vient dans ton truc juste tu
le défonce quoi
sur le dauphin peut pas être là non
normalement mais quand bien même il
viendrait juste tu les reçu il se perd
il arrive dans la Seine il fâchez pas
voilà tu le reçois
l'alligator ouais peut-être des
alligators peuvent venir ou quoi mais
bon c'est
passé hyper mal en fait de faire des
barrages
puis en plus tu dois ralentir l'eau pour
pêcher ou enfin je sais pas je pense
c'est aussi très pratique
il y a eu des coups la caméra
donc si ça bug
ouais ça buggé
ça bugge et c'est pour ça qu'on avait
plus de coup
s la caméra pour qu'on puisse voir
il a pas trouvé la tanière c'est logique
quand même
d'ailleurs tu peux quand même faire que
ce sera cloué
c'était beau quand même
je pense à faire
heureux de c'est 5 car il est C4
va te mettre le fond en D4 il va te
bloquer en fait
pas très bien jouer de la part de dépôt
là le B5 va me C7
creusé mais tu te dis je vais faire bien
français jour je suis tombé vite je suis
B2
mais en fait peut-être c'est trop simple
de blinder avec un fou des quatre et
compagnie quoi
avec visuellement c'est une bonne
tranche mais que dès que tu regardes un
peu plus de plus près
mais bon c'est quand même pas clair
enfin je sais pas trop
je sais pas c'est chaud quand même bah
ouais ouais c'est
encore un problème
pour qu'on puisse suivre la partie mais
en fait si ça bug
[Musique]
je vais me le mettre à droite pour
pouvoir le voir moi
c'est terrible ces bugs
ça arrive tellement souvent
ouais bon
même pas comment on peut encore des
problèmes de ce genre 2022
il y a jamais des
tours qui passent quoi
ça donne envie
je vais mettre la dame
c'est en combien de manches cette finale
c'est quatre manches
bah ça pourrait s'arrêter là sinon qui
gagne mais bon ça peut s'arrêter là mais
ça pourrait aller jusqu'en départage si
n'est pas en gagne une et qui est nul
ça peut
ça part sur un nom fumage de terrier
exactement
mesdames B6 ok hyper chaud
et la maman c'est l'inverse c'est les
coups qui sont en avance sur l'échiquier
et en retard sur la cam
étonnant étonnant Fab
en tout cas ça joue dame
après faut l'avoir bien accroché pour
pour jouer dame B3 dame c'est 5 dames C3
Damas 7
parce qu'il va y avoir cahier des 5
après ça va taper B2
non mais visuellement enfin genre moi
j'ai pas trop calculé mais je me dis que
il y a du potentiel quoi
pardon
aussi mais
OK
[Musique]
mais bon c'est dans ces dans ces cas de
quoi faire
il sait faire la partie précédente en
réalité
bien sûr que c'est dans ses cordes mais
il est dans les cordes
c'est corde contre corps de Fabien
là je pense qu'il faut qu'il fasse le
coup de la corde à linge
c'est quoi
dans la corde et bim ils te mettent un
coup dans la gueule
bon sport le catch
va prendre à tomber faut apprendre des
choses quoi c'est pas
du sport en tout cas rive je pense qu'il
faisait du sport il fait du sport
régulièrement
avoir un Hikaru là qui qui est en
difficulté après il doit savoir qu'il y
a sa position n'est pas désespérée mais
tu sais que tu peux pas tromper là tu as
pas le droit à l'erreur
ça chauffe quoi le moindre coût à côté
un peu peut faire tomber
il va vraiment falloir trouver les coups
et peut-être pas qu'un
tu es plutôt pourri Carlo plutôt pour ne
pas
oh franchement n'importe en fait
c'est pour les deux quoi
non mais dans le sens où bon ben écoute
les deux m'ont l'air plutôt bien joué
nous propose un beau spectacle enfin
j'ai pas de raison d'être plus pour l'un
que pour l'autre
[Musique]
peut-être quand même un peu plus pour
le bide pas que aussi pour pour Kiko et
pas le titre de champion du monde
je suis pas un anti carreau enfin je
finis enfin nada
et dame de mauvais dame de
pourquoi pas les dessins
et c'est un peu la merde
trop faible
encore conclure pour les Noirs mais
c'est une bonne tête
direct
ça doit revenir dans la même position en
réalité parce que la dame doit se
décaler ici probablement
[Musique]
le plus faible donc c'est avantage noir
dame cavalier fort en attaque dans ce
rapport matériel il vaut mieux attaquer
donc
hyper chaud
porte logique
B3 tu t'enfermes quoi
ça a été joué
voilà il y a un coup qui donne un énorme
avantage noir c'est tourbé 4
le plus normal de la position
si c'est tombé ca Dame des trois
évidemment dans ma 3 c'était c'était
bête
ça doit être ça sonne idée
de jouer c'est logique
vous prend des 5 c'est jouer c'est
logique
du coup logique prise enfin en fait tout
est logique là on va voir la qualité
il va prendre la qualité en soit dame C5
soit prisé mais
mon avis va faire ça comme ça
et tourner deux dames c'est 5
et donc c'est pour ça qu'en fait
cavalier prend pion prend Damme C5
échecs intermédiaires force 3 B1 il faut
prendre 5 c'est beaucoup plus fort
B3 Assieu par rentrer là-dedans
c'est pas trop
qui prend le 5 direct
mais c'était dur de voir dame c'est 5
étoile des deux
c'est juste qu'il joue tempo en fait
si il veut se poser il va il va
comprendre la subtilité ouais mais c'est
tellement automatique comme coup oui je
sais bien mais
mais là justement on a un niveau où on a
besoin de jouer hyper précis
non mais genre ça me fait penser parfois
je sais pas
ouais après là c'est du jeu rapide c'est
différent mais
tu t'attends que pour devenir champion
du monde tu te retrouvais des trucs durs
ça va pas que être des coups normaux que
tu joues avec la main quoi de tous les
de tous les jours
erreur
erreur du côté de nepo
il reste pas mal mais c'est vrai que
l'autre avait l'air allô je crois que
c'était terminé
après
[Musique]
papa chaque couche potentiellement
chaque couple
ça se trompe pas avec
après tu peux toujours jouer au hasard
mais là bon ça reste chaud enfin genre
c'est pas dit qu'il va s'en sortir inca
mais en tout cas lui a laissé une chance
quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'il va s'en sortir
il est à 13h sur la cam
souvent tu passes au bord du précipice
et que tu t'en sors c'est bon signe quoi
c'est très bon signe
non mais quelque part tu as un freerole
quoi la partie de voix déjà être perdu
et finie
bon il se trouve que tu es encore là
quoi
et tu as toujours pas perdu
c'est ça
grosse faute quand même de pas avoir
calé d'âmes c'est 5 c'est vrai
tellement des trucs de ouf
que
[Musique]
ça c'est facile en fait c'est plus de la
flemme qu'autre chose quoi de ne pas
l'avoir regardé
c'est plus de la flamme qu'autre chose
et ça peut coûter très cher
de gagner une partie quoi donc quand
l'opportunité il faut marquer quoi
mais bon
[Musique]
complètement
à cause des pions
c'est normal
enfin c'est compliqué
je sais pas quoi peut-être faire tourner
[Musique]
mais en même temps tu es content avec
toi
en fait là n'importe qui peut faire une
erreur ça peut vite tourner
ai comme ça avec les noirs
moi aussi mais t'es pas à l'abri de
faire une grosse couille ouais ou de
rater complètement l'initiative enfin
changer les dames et dans une finale à
la con
[Musique]
t'as l'abri de rien mais oui je pense
que c'est les blancs qui sont plus
proches de foot ici mais si tu joues un
deux bons coups avec les Blancs ça peut
se retrouver proche pour les Noirs en
fait
il va peut-être réfléchir un petit mot
ils ont repris leur 5 minutes au 30e
coups a été joué
Magnus c'est complètement gagnant
là c'est fini
donc minus va sur on prend la troisième
place
devant
quand il a pu éviter les positions trop
tactiques il aura toujours gagné Magnus
en fait
il a vraiment du mal quand il y a pas de
point de repère enfin du mal par rapport
au meilleur
qui va jouer un coup bientôt on le voit
un peu à l'écran
se tortiller
tu peux pas te laisser avec une ou deux
minutes ici dans une position pareille
il faut essayer de se garder un tout
petit matelas en cas de coup dur
là c'est un coup il semble avoir quand
même pas mal de choix
je veux dire c'est peut-être même juste
une histoire d'approche de Magnus par
rapport parfois on fait vraiment des
coups
si on l'air horrible mais qui marche
ouais
il s'en fout parce qu'il a vu qu'il a
l'agence et ses pièces et que Magnus il
fait quasiment jamais de trucs comme ça
trop sain ouais non mais franchement les
rares fois où il a vraiment fait un truc
que je trouve horrible mais en fait qui
marche bien c'était on est content
ensemble en plus c'était la
sicilienne là qui est C3
4 c'est 5 qui est trop 5 c'est 4 G6 H4
H6
en fait comprenez loin enfin que il
savait qu'il faut lutter pour la case
des 5 qui échangeait les pièces c'est
lui qui avait la personne un jour enfin
c'est juste qu'il est trop bien compris
mais c'était juste dégueulasse
visuellement je crois que c'était prépa
hein femme bah oui c'est sûr contre
Maxime et il a rejoue qu'on époque il a
gagné combien de dépôt et
donc c'était pas cam one shot en fait
mais c'est oui c'est que c'est prépa et
qu'il est bien poussé loin quoi
mais c'est une des rares fois que je me
souviens d'avoir un truc je me dire
waouh
c'est pas lui qui joue je me dis que le
mec est nul quoi
bon là vu que c'est Magnus je me dis bah
en fait c'est moi qui suis nul c'est moi
qui comprend pas et après en voyant la
partie tu comprends un peu où il voulait
en venir et d'ailleurs ça a été rejouer
après par d'autres joueurs et c'était
pas c'était pas idiot quoi comme concept
mais à part cette partie là que j'en
tête je sais pas il y en a peut-être
d'autres mais je vois trop rarement de
faire des trucs comme ça qui il peut pas
quoi c'est contre nature et en 960
justement peut-être
[Musique]
c'est un problème de pas pouvoir faire
des trucs bizarres comme ça
pas les envisager en tout cas
s'il doit se faire surprendre en plus
quand ça marche
j'ai alors l'ordi donne 17 comme
ça peut être mais c'est pas été joué
il faut 5 tours 3
ok donc
mais après on fait
peut-être te reprendre
je voulais faire des quatre F5 pour
dégager la tour de l'homme et des quatre
c'est pour prendre des vêtements
très complexe il fait des calculs
pour la règle d'enlever d'éliminer une
sorte de pièce
ça marche toujours ce truc là
tu peux te retrouver vraiment mieux avec
les Blancs
si tu réussis à bloquer le truc sur case
noir en Descartes
et que tu viens forcer les changer d'âme
d'une manière X ou Y pour gagner le pion
à 5
après il a assez facilement
pas encore mais ça commence à être de
moins en moins de résultats et de plus
en plus 3
ah ouais ouais voilà je suis pas sûr que
dans son grand mieux en fait
non un peu en fait
je sais pas comment tu dois tu dois
continuer ça torse OK
la dame va venir vers E4 non
je trouve ça logique d'essayer de garder
toi
façon le roi blanc est faible tu veux
garder le maximum de pièces puis là à
vrai dire il est quand même bien bloqué
pour le moment mais bon
oui tu décales vite vers tes 7 ou je
sais pas où
le problème c'est que tu as jamais deux
trois quand même pour aller lui prendre
des cases blanches qui sont cruciales
tellement complexe
quoi tout rêve de
je veux quoi
E2 alors
je pense que tu veux pas laisser la dame
s'infiltrer sur case blanche en fait
attention au plan de type à 4 fois 5
enfin peut-être à un moment donné si il
faut il rebondit vers à 5 il te plait
bien joué de la part des deux hommes ça
joue bien ce match
tout d'un coup je suis heureux un peu
inquiet pour les blancs
dans C4 tous ces 7 c'est un joli
agencement
peu de temps pour Ikao
3 30 contre 4 17
des pots qui jouent vraiment bien
on comprend pourquoi
n'est pas gagné les candidats et
Nakamura fini 3e
ils sont quand même extrêmement précis
un Fab
ouais il me faut un peu penser à mvl
2019 non
je sais plus 2019 qui a eu de
particulier mais
vraiment fort
mais peu importe en fait il a donné le
tout pour le tout pour gagner il aurait
même pu finir deuxième en réalité ça la
dernière fois
peu importe
en tout cas il va il va jouer un coup là
il hésite il a plus de 30 tours
tu as pas envie de laisser des trucs
quand même
c'est pour ça que le coup numéro 1 de
l'ordi c'est tourbé 5 ici et le coup
numéro 2 tours C2 c'est les coûts les
plus logique en fait mais bon tellement
dur à jouer
logique quand tu les as vu et quand tu
sais qu'il passe tactiquement en fait
un truc chiant tu laisses tout reprendre
des trois tu as pas d'âme
des deux moi je vais à 4
le faut arriver tout ça serait peut-être
fin de variante côté français
ça j'aurais pas envie de calculer plus
loin alors
tu penses
peut-être y arrive
je sais pas trop
c'est hyper chaud
et plus qu'une 406
[Musique]
mais bon faut avoir le sang froid pour
jouer ça
parce que c'est pas simple
tourter de je trouve que c'est plus
logique mais il va se prendre à quatre
en même temps c'est assez logique comme
quoi
comme
c'est 5 c'est fort pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut absolument genre si je fais à 4 moi
qui me paraît très
hyper logique
la défense est tombé 5 donc bon
F2 dame un roi G2 d'un machin roi H3
d'un point F3 peut-être des trois aussi
des croisillades
pour C3 ah oui il veut rentrer en 3
maintenant
tour des trois
pour ces deux tours des deux
DAMS
qui peut avoir son importance
et toi tu refais un gagne plus tu refais
un tour B2
mais bon pour ces deux tu as quand même
envie tu fais quoi
tu forces le jeu tu peux calculer
et puis les blancs en fait ont plus
aucune menace en fait ils sont pris ils
sont sur cases blanches mais ils ont
plus aucune intervention ils sont pris
dans les dans les taux du Fou et du pion
dame C43 ça gagne plus
à cause de tour B2 qui va être joué en
plus
marrante
d'après l'ordi mais bon ça reste que tu
es dans les cordes à fond ouais mais tu
sens quand même quand tu vas le tour
c'est de te reprends à deux machins que
ça revient un peu
ce que tu te recroquevill quoi
et tu fais un genre de blocus sur casse
blanche
et c'est bizarre j'ai l'impression de
dépôt des fois il manque le précisions
anglais quoi il clique trop en fait donc
quand il faut jouer le coup vraiment
précis
c'est un axe de progression pour lui
peut-être encore quoi qu'il a le bon
feeling il place bien les pièces il te
joue initiative enfin et aux échecs
normaux sont répertoires il devient bien
blindés tous c'est cool mais des fois tu
as le clic là tu peux finir la partie
quoi en fait avec le dame c'est 5 échecs
ou pas ça peut lui échapper
un H4 pour pas laisser le premier rg5
bien joué la chance à faire faux et 5 du
coup
surtout contre un tel comme Naka
c'est vraiment dur avec les gens avec
une minute enfin je sais pas comment il
compte s'en sortir quand même mais si on
a bien un qui est capable de s'en sortir
c'est lui c'est ça c'est bien lui le
marlou en chef
il est très heureux
là il est super heureux
je pense qu'il va s'en sortir
IKO
ce qui va
tenter un roi des deux peut-être autour
des deux
il est super heureux
le joueur américain il est libre et
tour à trois il a pas été très heureux
quand même
peut-être qu'il a pas eu le coup il y a
le pion à deux qui tombent
comment il va la jouer ikaro
H5 ouais c'est bien joué ça encore
ça va être quoi roi j'ai 7 j'imagine
tu me laisses pas à l'espion jusqu'en H6
non Fab
ouf j'ai 5
il a fait
peut-être plus le coup de l'ordi
d'ailleurs
pour empêcher 6 et
retrouver du lion
il reste plus beaucoup de temps à F4
puis on prend H5
bouffer ce Punto et parce qu'au final
quand tu prends à deux ça en fait
beaucoup d'âme F5 je me posais la
question de le bouffer devant ranger
cette en fait
est-ce que toi tu bouffes Fab les Punto
H6 bien joué
il veut damage 5 Fougères
peut-être qu'il doit décaler son roi à
la Hikaru peut-être trois pour aller
au F2 chercher des meilleurs cases c'est
bien joué et un peu moins heureux quand
même il danse moi mais il est quand même
heureux
qui tombe le roi qui repart vers G2
ça il a mis son roi à l'abri
et va les contre-attaquer avec avec ton
rêve 2 ou tout rêve 3
issue un peu là
bon
à deux c'est peut-être l'autoroute qui
part l'autoroute du Sud il va prendre
l'asset et la 8 sans phase Go maintenant
pour le pion à Fab
je crois qu'il en RS6
cette compliqué pour les tours du
carreaux de l'intercepter
le Champion du monde en titre qui suit
et là regarde l'ordi propose prise des
deux prises des deux et Fuger 5 pour
venir complètement enfermer cette dame
et envoyer le pion des
deux ça va faire mal après Fab
la ça suicoter quota américain c'est
encore le pion en réserve il a fait
fouger 5 d'abord
alors ah oui c'est moins fort parce que
tu reprends à deux dames prends à deux
tu dégages pas la tour
ça c'est chaud
d'abord
ouais
et là il y a juste F5
il y a juste F5 qui déclue et c'est
trouvé et c'est trouver Fab il va
égaliser une peau
dame 2 OH il tente encore il échange
foot en eux il va tenter un perpète
encore et il abandonne
ça tient pas le regard que tu es
américain
et que
ça sert pas les mains
c'est il y a peut-être un axe de
progression là dessus au niveau de la
commission d'éthique Fab quand même
peut-être montrer plus respectueuse
quand même non parti vite fait bien fait
ouais mais de toute part il y a pas que
il y a pas que Hikaru il y a pas que
Carole scène on a vu ça torof qui a fait
la même ça mériterait quand même
peut-être non je pense dans des sports
comme le judo ou quoi tu te comportes
comme ça
ça
cause échec c'est un peu partout
ouais mais tu trouves pas qu'il y a un
effort quand même à être fait pour
normalement oui c'est quand même pas
content de ta prestation c'est quelque
chose mais tu as le droit quand même de
serrer la main normalement à tes
adversaires
quoi que ce soit ton adversaire qui a
rien fait il t'a arnaqué mais c'est toi
le problème c'est pas la personne
tu sers pas la main enfin il y a des
endroits tu sors la main comme ça tu
sors pas du quartier frérot non mais oui
tu peux faire la main avec correction et
puis tu peux sert à rien de correction
et partir tu es pas la peine de de
serrer la main donner ta main de loin
en regardant pas ou quoi attention
un exemple pour la jeunesse quand même
franchement on serait fantastique si on
avait la commission d'éthique pour nous
quoi il y aura des débats
du serrage de main non bah je sais pas
c'est dans les règles quand même c'est
obligatoire
du coup on pourrait faire aussi des
échecs ping-pong moi je te jure pas avec
les mêmes règles que toi je m'en bats
les pièces dans la gueule enfin genre au
bout d'un moment chacun ses règles
en fait je trouvais dessus
non mais c'est normal le Salaman
normalement
de Grand Chelem les mecs vont au filet
ils serrent la main normalement
tu as pas un gars qui vient au tennis la
rare fois ou justement la poignée de
main est froide ça te fait les gros
titres des journaux machin comme la
moutarde récemment je sais pas ce qu'il
y a eu on en a parlé
mais même au foot tu ferais ça même dans
des sports comme ça
bon rugby tu te prendrais juste
ça
sera la main normalement quoi donc voilà
quoi non mais c'est juste que c'est
systématique c'est pas une fois de temps
en temps ou ce serait compréhensible
c'est réellement systématique en fait
tous les sports dont vous parlez la
poignée de main et à la fin des matchs
et pas eu ça oui mais là si c'était
qu'une partie ce serait pareil c'est pas
ça changera en fait
et puis c'est des mini match là c'est
enfin tu vois
enchaîne pas deux minutes après pour
jouer le prochain set là ils attendent
pendant une demi-heure non mais au pire
au tennis
j'accepte c'est pas un problème enfin
même à la boxe il sert à rien
voir discuter dans le chat enfin c'est
quand même nous qui avons joué au niveau
quoi c'est pas vous quoi on sait le truc
si on vous dit que c'est pas correct
c'est faut pas chercher à discuter
toujours sauver les gars que vous aimez
bien parce que vous les aimez bien ça
c'est pas ça toute mousse en regardait
s'il y a des gens qui te font ça dans la
rue enfin s'il y a des gens normalement
quand tu as ton travail ou quoi c'est
pas
la main et que le mec en face il se met
10 mètres de toi il donne la main vite
fait il se bat enfin c'est c'est pas
normal en fait
c'est pas correct
donc je sais pas c'est juste de la
correction en fait c'est même pas
histoire de niveau des enfin non c'est
pas une question niveau c'est mais c'est
juste c'est systématique c'est pas si ça
arrivait une fois de temps en temps
c'est une chose mais c'est réellement
systématique c'est toutes les parties
quand c'est long long il se sert la main
il discute faut arrêter de dire
n'importe quoi aussi bah pas toujours
c'est pas systématique c'est quand ils
font nuls qui font ça
peu importe
tu en as qui le font régulièrement pas
content de perdre tu es dégoûté quoi
enfin ça fait mal et c'est chiant mais
tant pis comportement à avoir tu es là
ça dure trois secondes de se faire une
main tu sors la main et puis bon
du niveau pour avoir dans ce cas il
kawaii Carlson qui ont plus de niveau
que toi savent mieux aussi mais enfin
abruti mon pauvre une définit quoi enfin
c'est incroyable en fait
en fait je veux dire quand je vous dis
ça c'est le niveau c'est que je pense la
plupart d'entre vous vous avez jamais
joué une partie en compétition vous avez
juste cliquer sur une souris donc vous
êtes mal placé pour parler de serrer des
mains qu'on doit toucher votre souris
quoi
non mais on amateur même en amateur ta
personne qui fait ça genre moi dans mes
parcs des gens qui me servent à la main
comme ça je me rappelle même pas en fait
je pense à mes quasiment jamais arrivé
bah non voir jamais en fait
non mais c'est pas que je suis énervé
mais ça va être je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'avec le chat dès qu'on
parle d'un truc tu as des gens qui
sortent de nulle part qui connaissent
rien qui viennent vouloir avoir raison
non quoi donc des fois c'est juste faut
pas défendre l'indéfendable c'est pas
normal le serrer la main comme ça en
fait c'est 12 points c'est pas grave
c'est une finale de championnat du monde
quand même enfin c'est pas c'est bon au
pire c'est pas un scandale enfin il y
aurait une quatrième partie et puis tout
le monde aura oublié et on s'en fout
quoi mais pas qu'on le dise il y a pas
de problème
à des gens qui font ça en fait c'est pas
possible dessin animé à des carrohanas
ou quoi qui sont toujours classe
et voilà
l'exemple du tennis avec
prof Fab Fab qui a été déco c'est
terminé on a perdu Fab oh
qui est venu qui est venu juste dégager
le Fab
bah non mais je suis là
tu as plus entendu tu as été censuré la
cam a disparu mais bon
je suis bien
[Musique]
mais non mais en plus le fait de serrer
la main correctement Jean c'est une
marque c'est tes parents qui
t'apprennent ça c'est une marque de
respect moi mon père quand j'étais gamin
il dit ouais il faut serrer la main aux
gens correctement et tout si ça repart
correctement tes
bah je sais pas c'est pas un truc qui
est causé chèque en fait de serrer la
main correctement aux gens que tu
rencontres genre même si tu fais tu vas
à ton travail ou dans des rendez-vous
même que soit la banque ou quoi tu sers
la main aux gens correctement
globalement non
mais si tu le fais pas c'est que c'est
sciemment c'est extrêmement manque de
respect bah ouais c'est genre c'est
connu que c'est pas respectueux de
serrer la main n'importe comment aux
gens si c'est même pas besoin d'être
joueur des chèques ou pas pour
comprendre ça c'est juste une des bases
du respect
je sais pas
j'ai même pas de quoi on débat en fait
c'est comme si le mec il est parti
sur les gens je sais pas des trucs que
tu fais ça c'est comme ça tu vois tu
craches pas tu craches pas dans ta main
avant de serrer la main aux gens enfin
je sais pas tu as une barre de respect
et le respect c'est fait justement pour
pas se prendre des coups sur la gueule
de base c'est pour ah tiens je te
respecte qui me respecte ah tiens ça va
tu vois on se met pas sur la gueule
passons à être de base bon tu respectes
pas les gens
ben non mais c'est ça si tu vas pas dans
la rue tu baisse ton froc sur les gens
genre tu sais que c'est irrespectueux tu
le fais pas voilà c'est pareil on t'a
aussi appris que serrer la main
correctement des gens ça non mais tu
sais que les gamins ils le comprennent
pas quand tu es complètement enfant
genre c'est truc qu'on tape à peu près
les règles un peu le respect le machin
et tout c'est pas des trucs c'est pas
c'est pas intuitif en fait et tu vois
les gens
respectueux ah bah tiens tu vas tout à
l'heure j'étais sorti avec là je suis
allé faire le marché il y a un petit qui
tapait sa sœur bon ben ça m'arrive
s'énerver oui tu n'as pas à taper les
gens tu peux pas taper ta sœur enfin je
sais pas en fait on t'apprend ces
choses-là c'est c'est même pas une
question d'échec en fait c'est bah quand
tu seras aux gens tu la regardes enfin
tu la regardes dans les yeux tu
on te suspend et puis tu apprends comme
quand tu es petit tu te prends une
punition quoi ouais
c'est différent là on parle d'une
pression de ouf à la Coupe du monde non
mais c'est quoi lecture en fait c'est
une pression de ouf moi j'ai envie de te
mettre un point dans la gueule en fait
ce que j'ai la pression parce que ça
détendent ça j'ai envie de te casser les
chéquier sur ta tronche bah non en fait
je sais pas c'est pas une excuse la
pression ça se passe parce que tu es
sous pression tu dois faire de la merde
tu te contrôle c'est s'appelle
l'éducation en fait
mais après ok c'est rien de super
dramatique mais c'est vrai que après
donner des prix du fair-play c'est
bizarre quoi
non mais j'ai l'impression que on dit
rien de particulier
qui étaient des serrages à salut sinon
j'ai pas j'ai pas l'impression qu'on
qu'on dise quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel femme
ça me paraît être les bases de vraiment
de l'éducation
tu as toujours vu ça partout enfin je
rentre la prends même pas c'est juste
une fait par mimétisme normalement le
fait normalement ouais
moi qui ai joué pendant longtemps machin
que ce soit en compétition jeune ou tu
as des gamins ou quoi
t'as jamais personne qui te sert mal la
main en fait t'as jamais personne qui
fait ça en fait
mais faut vraiment que ce soit mal passé
avec l'adversaire
mais il m'a quand même serré à la main
normalement par je sais pas comment dire
par réflexe en fait ouais c'est un
Italien ça appartient
vraiment voilà mais j'arrive à serrer à
la main complètement normalement
partie interminable qui avait pas duré
58 mais qui a été duré 7 heures il était
gagnant après une heure de jeu je
l'arnaque dans le dernier designotes
enfin je comprends il était écœuré en
fait ah c'était un truc imperdable et il
se fait arnaquer dans le dernier
designotes bon enfin il était un peu
sanguin il s'énerve il a quitté le
tournoi de lendemain enfin bon
correctement
il a fait une remontrance face à ce
n’est pas passé comme une lettre à la
poste pour lui après de m'insulter quand
même genre là tu as l'impression que tu
fais ce que tu veux alors que c'est une
finale de champion du monde genre tu
arrives tu donnes la main comme ça tu
jettes ta chaise enfin ça va quoi
piment les normes de respect c'est enfin
je sais pas je trouve ça normal
non mais c'est vrai que c'est fou tout
ce qui a le droit de faire aux échecs
juste
5 j'ai repris
l'US Open pour la balle sur la juge
complètement mérité après hein
je veux dire c'est c'est vert mais enfin
c'est comme ça même pas fait un scandale
il a pas gueuler quoi
je veux dire ça doit être Djoko
tu repars quoi
non mais ce truc là
c'est vraiment fréquent enfin c'est
fréquent chez deux joueurs surtout chez
Naka et Magnus
de faire ça mais c'est vraiment
irrespectueux enfin vraiment ce serait
enfin franchement je serai dans un sport
comme le rugby c'est ça se passerait
vraiment très mal
c'est très très vite tu aurais plein de
plein de gens qui t'entouraient et qui
vont être taper dessus c'est ce serait
je sais pas pourquoi aux échecs en fait
manquer de respect ça paraît normal même
aux gens je sais pas non non mais ça
paraît pas super normal
moi j'ai rien fait de mal je m'appartis
je t'ai même pas arnaqué en fait c'est
une partie qui n'est pas mérite en fait
donc ouais je vois pas que tu te barres
comme ça
je sais pas j'ai fait ma partie quand
même quoi
sur le dress code des années 20 mais ils
disent rien sur les poignets de mer non
mais c'est incroyable en fait non mais
on s'en fout quoi
[Musique]
normalement il y a pas de problème
Arabie ça arrive des mecs énervé
viennent pas serrer la main ça arrive
qu'il y a des basses en général après du
coup ça
enfin moi ça me paraît vraiment je vois
qu'il y a pas de gens qui trouvent ça
normal peu importe
la pression
donc forcément
il a failli la sauver il a failli sauver
un truc difficile mais il a fini par la
perdre mais au vu de la partie
quand même c'est normal
du coup c'est je crois que toi aussi tu
as ta cam qui est dans le noir même ce
que je mange OK
mais en plus aux échecs en fait le
serrage de main c'est un peu comme au
judo le salut ou tu le fais de manière
mais bon ça peut-être les gens le
comprennent pas
c'est un truc en fait qu'on t'apprend
des tout-petits quand tu vas au club et
c'est dit ok c'est vraiment important
c'est comme le salut au judo c'est comme
si les mecs ils faisaient pas enfin tu
es en finale champion du monde est un
des deux qui fait pas le salut au judo
ce serait très bizarre en fait
je sais pas tu es en dehors tu es pas du
tout mais en fait
non mais justement
tu peux pas en fait c'est juste que tu
vas assez à l'envers de
des valeurs qu'on transmet au tout jeune
nos écoles d'échec quand ils ont 6 7 ans
la valeur du respect de l'adversaire ou
quoi elle a tu as des mecs qui sont
finalement ils les ont pas ça veut dire
que demain les profs d'échec quand ils
vont aller dans les écoles quand ils
vont faire faire des tournois aux
enfants de 7 8 9 10 ans bah les mecs
c'est important c'est le respect c'est
les échecs en respectant c'est vraiment
lui bon il est Caro et Magnus ils le
font pas enfin non je te fais de
recettes et puis voilà enfin c'est
pareil on fait des nuls à ranger machin
j'accuse les gens de tricher au hasard
enfin c'est pas bien quoi
faut que tu reset
du monde quand même
enfin même si c'est un titre un peu
fantoche ça reste une finale de
championnat du monde
[Musique]
tu fais pas ce que tu veux quoi
je sais pas ce sera la fille d'être plus
moi c'est pas contre les joueurs c'est
plus la fille qui qui demande aucune
exemplarité quoi non mais c'est tout le
temps
[Musique]
comme ça c'est jamais hyper grave en soi
mais le tout cumulé tu te dis que c'est
bizarre quoi
je sais pas sortir d'un tournant avec un
gars de triche sans sans preuve oui non
mais je veux dire c'est
toujours les joueurs qui sont plus
importants que les tournois que
l'institution que
alors que ça devrait pas
un petit discours quelqu'un qui lance la
partie un officiel je sais pas
une trentaine d'années c'est sûr et j'ai
déjà vu plein de photos avant des
au début de la scène normalement la main
quoi bah oui
mais c'est bien bravo
j'ai trois dessins OK
voilà c'est normal en fait ce qu'ils
font ça doit être pareil à la fin en
fait
tu vois dans ta pièce et tu t'énerves si
tu as envie de
durer peu importe mais tant que tu es là
ouais tu dois
ben c'est vrai c'est comme si c'est
vraiment des trucs que tu apprends quand
tu es petit et qui font partie un peu de
la
le coup ça nous a fait le débat d'entre
partir de toute façon on a passé le
temps du
absolument rien à [ __ ]
complètement en fait c'est magnifique
il fait des quatre OK
bon c'est un autre type de position du
coup
[Musique]
tu vas leur dire qu'il propose de foudre
c'est le fou BK
est-ce que tu peux tenter de faire un
petit fou des deux fois si
ça se foutait
par terre parce qu'il est énervé il
ramasse en avertissement direct bah oui
c'est normal et encore c'est pas des
trucs de respect par rapport à
l'adversaire c'est juste en match parce
que c'est un très mauvais exemple et que
tes professionnels tu dois pas le faire
mais bon aux échecs j'ai l'impression
que dès que tu parles le
professionnalisme et machin
on va pas repartir là dessus Fab
ot de tester la limite et vraiment
essayer de pisser sur ça une partie
[Musique]
c'est inacceptable
genre en fait
sur l'adversaire bon ça passe ça va on
va essayer un peu plus la prochaine fois
ce serait magnifique en fait
gestion de départ alors il la change
ouais en fait il joue deux positions
différentes par match et une fois dans
les blancs une fois dans les noirs pour
équilibrer parce que il se peut que
parfois la position soit très supérieure
pour les blancs hier on a eu un cas de
figure en fait c'était quand même sympa
de commencer avec les Blancs
et donc c'est équilibre de jouer
avec les deux couleurs
de l'adversaire et remettre sur une case
random ça passe par exemple ça oui ça
passe c'est vous quoi essayer tous les
conneries à faire alors ça passe ça
passe pas quoi
il est assez normal quoi sinon enfin
normal
U6
plus rien mais bon surtout plus de dame
en plus je pense que c'est le bon coup
tu vas revenir vers les cases
ça a pas l'air très fort
il n'y a pas le fond en sert en fait
non mais en fait
[Musique]
ok bon pourquoi pas je sais pas il y a
des droits je vais bien mais peut-être
que ça c'est bien aussi
c'est compliqué de toute façon
il était surpris d'avoir le roi dans les
mains
dans ma vision du truc tu vois ces gens
qui pète un plomb quoi
ça arrive machin que pour pour des
manques de respect répétés mais après ça
c'est moi
c'est juste un bug mental en fait
je pense qu'il sait même pas ce qu'il
fait quand il le fait
non mais c'est fou ça c'est juste
déconnexion complète quoi
c'est bizarre ça se voit qu'il sait pas
il croise ce qu'il a fait juste après
là des connexions la carte mère
je compte plus mais c'était qu'on
partait normalement toute la partie quoi
il est pas du tout que tu mets de du
fait quoi
non plus je crois qu'après il voulait le
réparer quoi j'étais pas bien quoi j'ai
foutu quoi je pense quand tu es en face
tu as Lucile
c'est assez hallucinant
derrière aux couleurs de l'Ukraine je
sais pas elle est tous les jours là il
est tous les jours habillé en bleu et en
jaune donc j'imagine mais
j'en sais absolument rien
d'autre arbitre plus ou moins je pense
qu'elle arbitre pas par déduction
j'imagine que oui mais
ça ça va peut-être faire une nulle
incipit
de faire un petit cahier des deux à un
moment
où je sais pas quoi que tu changes ça et
après c'est Armageddon direct alors
si jamais
ouais
on va voir
tu dis combien de temps tu veux quoi
pour combien de temps tu prends les
noirs
et s'il donne la même
je pense sur référent cher
peut-être un jour les fous je sais
peut-être même tout de suite
les deux
je pense aller en Armageddon en chair
mais bon si il fait un truc comme F5
avec les Noirs peut-être qu'il est un
peu mieux
je pense qu'avant de faire l'enchère il
faut savoir la position
tu as perdu sauf si ton adversaire il
décide que on fait nul quoi
en fait il y a eu un cas de figure comme
ça
un match France - arbaïdjan je sais plus
c'était un championnat d'Europe ou une
Olympiades et
je crois que c'était Maxime qui jouait
contre gashimov
joueur azéré qui a des gros problèmes de
santé en fait maintenant il est même
décédé il était jeune
et en fait en pleine partie il a fait
une crise
et il peut plus jouer enfin je sais pas
si fin et en fait maxime a accepté de
faire nul et les trois autres joueurs de
l'équipe de France ont fait nul aussi
parce que tout le monde était choqué
autour ou quoi
d'ailleurs assez sympa de la part de
l'équipe de France qui aurait pu juste
gagner le match en plus même le match se
passait pas trop mal enfin je vais
rester pas gagnant ou quoi mais ils ont
donc ils ont été très sympas de faire
plein quoi ça pourrait être un prix du
fer plaît pour le coup
voilà c'est le seul cas de figure que je
connais mais sinon on soit tu dis bah
moi je veux jouer ben j'imagine que tu
as gagné d'après le règlement
on serait beau de les battre quand même
être pas leur serrer la main connard une
crise d'épilepsie je te déteste
OK
en fait ça pas du tout faire nul la
position est très chaotique
mais pas vite en tout cas
qui fait la
à un moment donné qui te force un peu à
faire G4
on peut y aller à la tour en l'air quand
même pour le moment bah c'est ça
un problème pour ok regarde la dame elle
quand même niveau
comment
mais comment solutionne le schmilblick
grand rock le 7 reste en l'air
d'égalité mais je sais pas je sais pas
comment solutionner le fait
pour tout le monde le côté noir pour les
blancs
aussi
hyper bizarre comme partie
comment on rock tu rock comme tu recnes
normalement c'est à dire si ta dame là
avec les Blancs n'est pas là tu prends
ton roi tu vas maintenant géant
tu veux faire grand rock tu as tout à
côté tu la mets à la place voilà c'est
la position du rock normal
compliqué
[Musique]
la rupture ou pas enfin d'échanger ou
pas cette décision c'est eux qui va être
une petite pression quoi
peut-être que quand tu fais dames et un
peu plus de C4 aussi
et tu vas sur DC du coup tu pourrais
peut-être prendre 4 et venir rejaillir
et
les pots qui réfléchit
non mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
souvent que c'est les noirs
c'est encore une partie où c'est les
noirs qui sont mieux c'est bizarre
c'est sûr parce que les êtres humains
jouent mal forcément les blancs qui sont
mieux au début
peut-être on veut trop parce que tu as
les blancs
doit être enfin que si c'est égal et
noirs sont mieux et du coup on doit mal
évaluer ça doit nous griser
premier à jouer premier à faire de la
merde c'est ça
on n'est pas en tout cas qui qui est
concentré
parce que
H2O
c'est très responsable une décision
c'est peut-être mauvais mais en tout cas
ça se responsable
c'est peut-être bon aussi
j'aime pas
logique de reprendre mais la question se
pose mais de F ça paraît plus logique
que rajoute la pression sur F4 mais il
va jouer parce que
je pense et tous les jours de F ouais
[Musique]
tous les jours
ça me paraît juste étonnant
qu'il est pas encore repris ce que ça
paraît vraiment tous les jours de F
je vois pas dans quel cas c'est
délicieux en fait il doit être
d'ailleurs
bon il se projette il demande mais oui
ça arrive souvent c'est plus la Quentin
faut le faire ça te fait un coup de main
à calculer pour la suite
sinon ça fait aucun sens
peut-être
c'est même pas vraiment une menace
non mais ok pour mettre le foot dans un
terrier
c'est particulier c'est tente de jaune
différentes entre le haut et le
quelqu'un qui le disait tout à l'heure
dans le chat c'est vrai qu'une fois que
tu as vu ça tu arrives pas à regarder
autre chose
[Rires]
pourquoi c'est pas le même jaune en fait
ouais c'est un peu particulier ouais une
fois que tu le vois ça te
en fait
on dirait les coureurs non mais ça
clairement mais c'est juste pourquoi le
jaune n'est pas le même entre l'eau et
le bas
c'est une robe plus une veste ouais mais
c'est bizarre que soit deux coloris
de teintes de jaune différents après je
suis peut-être pas au fait de la mode
non mais moi ça me
OK
Théodore qui dit c'est dégueu
de on peut faire confiance
tu fais de monochrome soit deux teintes
vraiment différentes là c'est moche
c'est ce que je me dis aussi
c'est des jeunes qui sont proches l'un
de l'autre mais en même temps ils sont
vraiment
faire un truc comme toi F5 rock Dame des
cales
et E3 à un moment donné non ça va être à
peu près ça
peut-être qu'il fait froid et qu'elle a
mis la veste au dernier moment ok ouais
ça ça fait sens
ouais ok c'était pas elle était pas
censée avoir la veste OK
donc toi F5 c'est aussi de protéger le
Punto
qui a pris grand Rock sera attaqué
puisque
il prend F4 en première ouais
généralement on aime bien retarder le
maximum ce genre de prise parce que
c'est une pression dans la position mais
mais là c'est vrai que ça allait tous
les jours être prises après dans tous
les cas
bon je comprends
[Musique]
il menace 3 j'ai envie de te dire sinon
le pion il est cloué mais il fait grand
rat qui va te faire trois
ils ont fini ah ils ont fait nul
ils ont fait nul ouais ils ont fait
nulle
d'accord
bon
en même temps
[Musique]
mais je pense qu'il faut attendre la fin
de l'autre partie
ça dit qu'on passe une pause du coup on
va essayer de d'avoir les infos
et après on fait une pause
parce que tu peux tu peux mettre les
chier de l'autre partie il y a pas de
souci pour ça
comme ça on va ce qui se passe un peu
parce qu'à mon avis il va falloir c'est
quand même important d'attendre la fin
de la du match à 3e place pour pour
lancer starmakedon Fab
non mais en plus pour le goûter
c'est juste c'est le problème de match
en même temps mais tu vas pas revenir
avec faire du bruit et non non mais au
contraire c'est c'est tant mieux donc là
tu dois attendre on attend pour
être sûr ça coupe bien le moment
et puis peut-être faut attendre aussi
pour leur donner une nouvelle position
et bien leur laisser un quart d'heure
pour je pense qu'il va falloir aussi et
du coup tu vas peut-être attendre la fin
de ce match là
il y a deux deux ils ont pas le même
temps pour attendre la position
peut-être ils peuvent parler entre eux
mais je sais pas combien mais ça peut
vraiment leur magasin peut être dans
trois quarts d'heure
bien longtemps et tu dois attendre la
fin pour tirer au sort la position tu
dois laisser un quart d'heure pour faire
le truc après tu as les enchères on sait
pas trop il tombe sur la même enchère tu
refais une enchère enfin ouais mais
j'espère
j'espère Fab en fait j'espère que cette
partie va bien durer faut garder en fait
ils ont fait nul par accord mutuel
du préalable
c'est la règle c'est écrit comme ça
quoi
que les que les matchs ont les mêmes
positions
pour avoir des positions différentes
c'est d'accord bon après pourquoi pas
enfin je reçois ça me choque pas mais ça
pourrait aussi ça me changerait pas non
plus en fait
ah oui surtout qu'il y a quatre matchs
en même temps
parce qu'il y a aussi le match pour la
5e place et le match pour la 7e place ça
joue ça joue aussi ouais
on peut regarder quand même
ah oui mais c'est dommage de pas
regarder
alors au rugby à 7
ou tu as aussi beaucoup de matchs parce
qu'ils font les matchs de classement
les matchs ne jouent jamais en même
temps
en fait les matchs de classements
servent pour laisser au joueur le temps
de récupérer avant enfin au rugby c'est
difficile de jouer les matchs 10 minutes
les uns après les autres quoi je
récupère deux trois heures avant de
rejouer
non mais c'est pas mal enlevé de rideau
d'avoir des trucs
aussi donc tu as peut-être plus le temps
de le faire
donc ça c'est le match pour la 7e place
j'imagine
ouais c'est pour ça que souhaitais là en
fait hein
ouais ouais bon
il y a pas de n'hésitez pas à nous dire
si vous avez sur le stream en anglais
mais moi les infos que j'avais c'était
qu'il y avait un magasin direct j'ai lu
les règles mais après j'ai pu j'ai pu
rater
en soit de Bleach me semblerait plus
logique hein
peu importe et pourquoi pas en fait ça
fait très plaisir ça veut dire qu'il
doit vraiment tout attendre pour pour
jouer tu es vraiment obligé d'attendre
la fin de tous les matchs donc c'est les
ça se fait que ce soit vraiment dans une
heure
non mais vraiment ça va être dans très
longtemps c'est sûr
mais ça y est Oscar
ce qui est absolument magnifique
c'est quoi un magasin c'est une partie
où les Noirs ont moins de temps mais
derrière Armageddon 960 c'est con il
faudrait faire une mort subite
soit les noirs sont pas tant des
avantages et que ça
non
ça va être en chair donc c'est différent
mais je pense en fait c'est 6 minutes
contre 5 tu dis 5 avec les Noirs tu as
pas à dire moi en fait
aux échecs classiques on va dire la
règle normale c'est toujours une partie
d'échec
juste les blancs plus de temps donc ils
ont 5 minutes qu'on 4 ou 6 contre 5 ou 4
enfin partent et juste par contre tu es
obligé de gagner avec les Blancs
ont gagné le match quoi
exactement ça ce serait genre au foot on
te laisse je sais pas 10 minutes à jouer
à 11,9 par exemple et tu dois absolument
marquer si tu marques pas tu as perdu
c'est ça le truc et
voilà et donc là mais ils vont faire ça
en 960 mais c'est vrai que ce qui change
par rapport à d'habitude c'est qu'au
temps aux échecs normaux bon bah déjà tu
peux te lancer ta prépa et on sait
qu'avoir les blancs bon c'est quand même
un avantage
qui se voit pas toujours mais je veux
dire en soi voilà là ici on a vu au
résultat qu'en fait c'est hyper
équilibré donc
après bah évidemment l'avantage c'est
que tu peux jouer pour mettre la
pression à la pendule
ouais c'est complexe
peut-être pas vraiment davantage à la
position mais tu peux cliquer vite pour
faire tomber mettre la pression autant
voilà
mais généralement on aime bien avoir les
Noirs en fait ce truc
parce que c'est agréable de savoir que
tu peux faire nul des fois tu as des
positions tu es un perpète qui traîne ou
quoi PAF
je vais faire des chantages à la nulle
complexe
tu te renseignes du coup pour les règles
ouais
quelqu'un qui écrit un truc à temps
c'est quoi cette règle player Trade
Center une every game the place ah ouais
bah sûrement ils ont un truc
Gibraltar ou dans certains tournois tu
dois jouer avec
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs encore
la partie du cœur est terminée il y a eu
nul du coup ils ont fait deux deux et ça
va se jouer en départage on sait pas si
un départage Blitz avant l'arrivée donc
c'est un mari donc direct a priori ça
sera armagué donc direct
mais on attend le la confirmation du
règlement
ok apparemment c'est j'ai une info donc
c'est apparemment il va falloir attendre
que toutes les parties soient terminées
avant l'armagadon
OK et peut-être qu'ils aient un peu de
temps pour se familiariser avec la
position quoi
c'était le truc logique en fait après le
temps qu'il fasse des enchères le machin
et tout ouais on est pas sorti de
l'auberge hein
ce sera la grande finale du truc on sait
pas quand c'est
non mais parce que là en fait ils ont
encore beaucoup de temps
ils ont même pas eu leur rajout ils ont
encore 10 minutes chacun ils vont avoir
encore 10 minutes de rajout c'est sûr
que ça finit au moins dans une
demi-heure ouais juste le tirage au sort
de la position en plus les enchères plus
machin oui dans une heure enfin je pense
21h30
pire je sais pas tu as fait une pause on
revient pour 21h et puis on check un peu
où ça je pense que tu en penses
tu veux faire une pause maintenant vous
en pensez quoi le chat bon mais comme
vous voulez enfin on peut se passionner
pour qu'il va finir 7e ou 8e aussi mais
ça c'est le match le plus patient non
celui pour la 7e place
il y a un peu des deux tu vois ces gens
qui disent d'autres non
enfin pas de pause ou pas pause allez un
vote c'est bien le vote
[Musique]
non mais j'ai pas vraiment besoin
un petit truc mais c'est pas très grave
si on reste on reste il y a pas de
problème
ah non après c'est notre rêve de faire
un stream de pause quoi ah bah oui bon
ça pour le principe c'est bien
on va voir on fait voter
ça a voté pour pas de pause mais on peut
quand même le faire
ça va
merci la patronne je la patronne qui
m'envoie les ravitaillements
ça peut parfois avoir ses avantages
ou même triplé de volume impressionnant
tout d'un coup
la patronne de Baki qui m'a dit qu'elle
allait qu'elle allait passer en février
si elle va venir voir la nouvelle
patronne
c'est un monde de patronne en fait en
fait avec Baki on va pas être bien quoi
la petite
ouais
après il paraît finalement que les deux
premiers mois
mais il paraît que les deux premiers
mois c'est pas les plus durs
donc il paraît que c'est surtout à
partir du troisième
mais bon après tu peux pas savoir enfin
ça peut tomber aussi à être 4 enfin on
peut pas savoir en fait
tantôt qui confirme mais après j'aurais
mon rythme de croisière
mais je pense j'ai trouvé un truc pas
con pour le stream
parce qu'en fait ils disent que le bébé
tu le couche à minuit en gros il faut se
relever vers 2h30 3h du matin
en fait il y a un truc pas con c'est que
moi je peux finir mes streams vers 2h30
3h
rendormir le petit ou la petite fin la
petite plutôt et après pion c'est Eliana
elle peut elle peut faire le relais de 6
heures ou 7 heures
je pense ça peut être assez smartphone
je sais pas ce que tu penses de la
strate
c'est pas mal enfin
je pense c'est dur à priori que tu
planifies à l'avance ouais mais j'ai
quand même des strates
tu peux en préparer à l'avance ouais
mais bon tu peux quand même avoir des
strates
comme prévu
il veut une pause ouais non mais on va
faire une pause
c'est non pas possible il y a
51%, mais c'est pas assez grand quoi
ouais non mais tu peux aller faire une
petite pause là déjà Fab moi de toute
façon j'arrête pas trop de leur avito je
vais enlever la cam je vais rester un
peu là en
semi-pause et puis tu reviens 21h yes
j'arrête la vidéo moi de mon côté voilà
c'est ça exactement à tout de suite à
tout de suite
tu as quel âge j'ai 35 ans
très exactement
changer
ok attendez
attendez attendez
[Musique]
donc ouais non ça va être long encore
si c'est quand la troisième place en
fait mais ça bloque
ça bloque le tournoi principal en fait
n'a qu'à n'est pas on fait une ouais
ouais ils ont fait nul rapide
bon je suis en semi pose aussi je vous
le dis je regarde mes trucs la partie
est pas super passionnante façon on est
là pour l'Armageddon
complexe
quelle place les deux là c'est la
troisième place mais
la position est nettement mieux pour
enfin nettement mieux aller complètement
égal et d'où ça t'auras il va jamais
gagner ça avec les Blancs
alors c'est parti non mais je regarde un
peu le truc puis je regarde un peu mes
trucs aussi en toute façon six heures
d'affilée à regarder des échecs c'est
pas possible non plus donc il faut bien
faire une pause à un moment je reste là
un peu pour contrôler ce qui se passe
quelque chose mais et puis je regarde un
peu les infos je regarde un truc sur mon
phone
mais ceci comme ça que je viens de
choper l'info qu'on attendait la fin des
quatre parties
complexe
à la place ouais je sais pas on va
attendre
cette proposition de nulle qui fait un
peu de mal
complexe
ouais là le truc c'est que le cavalier
en F4 est trop fort
j'espère que ça va commencer pas trop
tard
c'est juste des anciens on l'a déjà
expliqué en fait je leur ai expliqué 10
fois d'affilée mais ça a déjà été
expliqué
ils vont faire des enchères pour savoir
avec combien de temps ils sont prêts à
prendre les noirs et
ouais à mon avis ils vont descendre
assez bas on verra jamais vu dans cher
en 960 donc j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis
mais ouais on verra bien de façon
combien ils ont de temps au début de la
partie après
de toute façon c'est pas filmé donc on
sera mis sur le fait accompli
donc là on va que Magnus
22 88
la position est catastrophique Magnus
qui va terminer troisième
la dame G2 il va se faire échanger les
dames il va perdre G4 c'est terminé
cette game aussi
non mais en plus là je regardais je
regardais Twitter aussi c'est
c'est le gros bordel
un Twitter c'est devenu à tous les jours
une dinguerie en fait
ok bon là c'est kata c'est kata G4 qui
tombe
enfin kata il peut peut-être la sauver
mais il doit gagner avec les Blancs et
ça ne va pas être le cas
Magnus qui va s'envoler vers la médaille
de bronze
du tournoi qui aura vraiment largement
dominé à qui pourra être un peu déçu de
sa défaillance tactique contre Yann la
torgée un cavalier 2 qui va faire mal
et sinon si il est vite par B3 roi B2
c'est tour tour
rage 4 touches 5
et ça va gagner
pas au moins faire nul
[Musique]
complexe
ne rage quitte non mais on va attendre
mais c'est juste ça casse complètement
le rythme
complexe B4 jouer mais vous voyez de
façon avec la jauge aussi
un peu un peu facile
yoyo
Magnus facile
Magnus très facile Magnum
mais oui je crois qu'il faut vraiment
attendre la fin des 4 parties
et oui
c'est trop en fait
et il paraît ils avaient dit de base que
qu'on verrait un peu les le
tirage au sort de et le tirage au sort
de la position etc mais en fait non ils
vont le faire dans dans l'arrière salle
donc on le verra pas
bon c'est pas grave en même temps
donc ce sera 10 minutes pour la partie
ok donc du blond en 10 minutes ça c'est
clair c'est ça et après il vote avec les
Noirs il va avec les Noirs ouais
bah vu comment ça se passe attends
je pense qu'il doit y avoir j'ai pas la
c'est censé de sinon je sais pas
à partir du 60e ou un truc comme ça mais
ça j'ai pas l'info
en disant que le mec va mettre ça 30 un
peu marlou
non
ce qui est vraiment facile
donc Abdou qui a fait des supercalifs un
peu trop haute à partir des à partir des
demi
avoir là c'était plus de marche pour lui
ouais c'était plus fort après dommage
j'ai des faïences de Magnus
hier
non mais je sais pas enfin moi je pense
pour un manque de forme mais bon on
verra
ampoule ça avait donné quoi contre
carreaux en fait vous avez fait des nuls
c'est ça
que c'était pris le truc on a tout vu le
dame 4
ok défaillance
de motivation peut-être oui bah c'est
pas
c'est pas possible
mais avant il est gagné tous ces
tournois un peu d'importance moindre
maintenant moi
[Musique]
tout marché de toute façon
on a tellement l'air blasé ouais mais
Magnus ça peut pas l'intéresser de finir
3e
il est là mais
moi je suis une légende chez moi
largement bah c'est souvent le cas
c'est souvent des matchs qui
m'intéressent pas grand monde
là qui en plus
ralentissent le tournoi donc je crois
qu'il faut que les deux autres parties
se terminent aussi
pas trop le choix
ça a l'air d'être assez clair je vois
pas sauter ça
qui finira 6e
ut
non mais
bel événement
ouais juste faudrait que les kiffe soit
un peu différentes et après oui bon tu
trouves un autre format où je fais pas
je tourne en même temps machin comme là
à la fin mais bon ça ça s'arrange
enfin ça s'arrangera pas en fait Fab non
c'est pas trop dur
c'est dommage la finale que ça que ça
fasse ça s'écroule un peu quoi
il y a que la finale qui nous intéresse
après on peut regarder pour regarder des
positions autre chose mais
ouais c'est pas c'est pas logique en
fait je n'ai même pas au courant qu'il y
a d'autres matchs en fait
qui avait la petite finale j'ai appris
hier mais bon ok bon admettons enfin
déjà c'est pas indispensable mais bon
admettons marquer les autres
tu sues non enfin je suis vite fait
c'était pas indispensable
ça te décale le coup d'envoi quand même
de ton Armageddon de trucs final
l'apothéose du tournoi d'une heure où on
attend on sait pas quoi en fait ah ouais
ouais c'est
ce qu'on attend pour la peine oui
on sait pas pourquoi
c'est mal à la taille de l'objectif
c'est mal à la taille de l'engin
mais ça va tu vas être heureux avec avec
Championship Fab la semaine prochaine
[Rires]
ça ça va être la rigueur
ça a l'air de faire mal non
je vois pas comment il va faire
facile
de
il va se faire on va se rendre fou H4 il
sera obligé de faire perpète non
mais alors dis donne gagnant au noir
j'ai l'impression que quand
mais il allait se faire bouffer B6 en
force OK
avec un zigzag de la dame ah oui donc en
fait sauf à égaliser
mais ça va aller en fait pour les noirs
[Musique]
pas mal d'enchères ça va être un beau
bordel
à mon avis c'est un problème de
retransmission là
mais là on a pas de vidéo pour nous
sauver
on n'est pas vernis
ok son coup pourquoi pas
les noirs
j'ai aucune idée de du temps
je suis obligé parce qu'on voit la
caméra
on peut rien faire à part attendre
désolé il y a vraiment rien à dire c'est
c'est
top sur Tuche avec l'échiquier en tout
petit format en fait pourquoi tu as
autant de gens qui se créent l'échiquier
et tout petit j'arrive pas à comprendre
encore un mec qui écrit sur Twitter je
peux pas comprendre en fait il est pas
petit l'échiquier
parce que là moi tu regardes ça mon
recours régie
tu le vois largement
ouais mais c'est quand même intéressant
la vidéo
surtout maintenant là
mais sur téléphone moi j'ai regardé ça
tu vois largement
wow après je sais pas
l'argent on pourrait alterner mais
bon a priori c'est censé suffire mais
bon en tout cas ok c'est un
intéressant pour les prochains trucs de
savoir que quand c'est dans ce format là
ça leur plaît pas trop
j'imagine que enfin on peut garder ça
comme format principal et puis de temps
en temps on switch on met les chiens en
très grand et les caméras un peu plus
petit et voilà
ça nous a sauvé tellement de fois pour
voir l'échiquier quand il était pas à
jour
moi je vois l'argent sur mon téléphone
l'écran
téléphone tu peux zoomer ouais aussi
d'ailleurs c'est vrai ouais en fait tu
peux avoir les chicons ouais non mais
sur téléphone tu zoom ouais complètement
enfin ça je le savais mais j'avais
oublié tellement il est visible mais oui
si tu veux tu peux zoomer sur
l'échiquier
donc je vois pas je comprends pas où est
le problème en fait non pas trop mais
bon après
ouais tu zoom en fait complètement je
savais j'ai déjà eu fait mais là quand
j'en avais pas le besoin
ils ont un ordinateur et une personne
qui fait une régie en fait
non mais il est dégueulasse ce truc
chasse comme
ils ont léché ils ont pas la caméra en
fait sur chess com voilà actuellement
mais généralement j'ai jamais vu
plusieurs fois ils mettent pas la caméra
en fait il met juste l'échiquier
c'est dommage
non on voit pas les joueurs et comme
c'est ce que je veux plein de reprises
en fait tu vois pas les joueurs ils te
mettent les chicas en grand et quand je
commande sur ma chaîne parce que j'ai
pas les caméras tu as les gens me disent
c'est dommage qu'on ait pas les caméras
et là quand du coup il te disent c'est
mieux sur chescom parce que si la caméra
tu la mets en tout petit là bah tu vois
comme c'est du 16/9 elle va être
minuscule à la place de l'échiquier tu
auras un truc minuscule et tu verras
absolument rien à la cam
c'est pas 1% des vieux tu as plein de
gens qui l'ont écrit ils ont eu des
commentaires
des gens
je trouve c'est top au contraire bah de
toute façon
mais ouais c'est bizarre de préférer le
truc sans caméra
mais c'est vrai que les autres si tu
veux voir juste les coups et tu t'en
fous des joueurs
les autres pays mettent la caméra en
tout petit et ils mettent les chiquer en
grand
moi je préfère tellement l'inverse
du moins si les joueurs arrivent au
courant on va aller voir enfin c'est
pour ça aussi que j'achète la cam même
si il se passe rien
mais on sait quand ça commence
bizarre pour moi j'aime bien avoir les
gilets la caméra en très grand en
principal et le reste en petit
surtout que on a deux joueurs hyper
expressifs pour la finale
n'est pas bien Chi et Nakamura donc
c'est fait dossier F qui a gagné
donc saucisse
en tout cas pour l'Armageddon c'est sûr
que la caméra en grand c'est mieux alors
là il y a même pas d'hésitation à voir
mais je trouve que mise à part pour les
parties longues sinon c'est mieux de
enfin bon après c'est un goût personnel
même après ce que tu as pas les caméras
j'en dise que c'est dommage on peut
importe
mais bon
sport où on peut très bien faire sans
aucune caméra sans rien juste on diffuse
les coûts
bah oui on voit un peu les joueurs et
tout ça change c'est sympa
on a fait changement de cam avec les
chiquiers la cam grand plan on en a deux
tu vois on profite un peu de
l'atmosphère on verrait pas bien le
public le machin voilà je crois qu'ils
ont tous fini
donc blue boom qui finit 7e fais dossier
F5E Magus 3e
du coup
c'est bon on a vraiment attendu 40
45 58 minutes vraiment dans le vent quoi
puis là ça a pas encore repris il va y
avoir le tirage au sort de la position
puis le tirage au sort du machin
d'Armageddon puis 5 minutes d'analyse
après ça jouera
Magnus pierreforme égale podium
complètement après il faut voir aussi
qu'il y avait énormément de joueurs
qui sont pas dans les meilleurs mondiaux
dans ce tournoi parce que très
franchement fait de CIAF blueboom Greta
sonne
c'est pas c'est pas exceptionnel
Wesley il est quand même en total perte
vitesse depuis la fin animal
honnêtement moins bien et Abdou ça Torah
on va pas appeler ça un top mondial donc
c'est pas mon avis il manque
quand même bah dans l'étape ils m'ont
créé ça déjà qui était plus fort que
tous ceux que je viens à des raisins
[Musique]
je peux prendre plein de joueurs
qui
qui joue peut-être un peu moins en ce
moment genre je pense ça peut penser à
Maxime à rognan des joueurs comme ça
mais qui dépailleraient pas du tout et
puis tu peux avoir plein de jeunes
prometteurs donc là c'est bien il y a de
cette offre mais tu pourras avoir des
des goûts caches des ce que tu veux quoi
donc tu as le choix avec beaucoup de
joueurs qui pourraient être là mais j'ai
8 ça sert restrictif après que tu en es
8 dans une phase finale pourquoi pas
mais qui a des califes avant
bonne et due forme quoi c'est dommage
et de le citer désolé oui il mériterait
il mériterait
le prendre sans problème
de toute façon c'est pas
sur sur 8 c'est beaucoup trop de toute
façon mais
[Musique]
diri d'ailleurs que j'ai oublié
rapporte qui peut être bon sur ce genre
de truc
et puis voilà bah après tu vas faire des
grilles de choses tu vois des
mots
[Musique]
il y a pas de souci
je le vois pas gagner mais pourquoi pas
enfin il pourrait jouer quoi
qui monte là en ce moment bizarre enfin
bizarre pas bizarre mais je vais reparle
je pensais qu'il avait complètement
cuite et il a 27 11
il y a pas confirmé bon il se trouve
qu'il est plus de 2007 quand même mais
on l'attendait plus enfin plutôt ou plus
fort enfin là ou l'autre quoi
genre il y a 10 ans quoi
là il est plus si jeune j'imagine non
il a 28 29 ans
mais bon voilà
c'est beau mais c'est pas
qualifiés si les autres avaient la